well what are the primary reasons that
we tell other people stories about our
lives
what are the primary reasons we tell
people stories about our lives
uh first of all it's varied a lot of
reasons
but the i think the important thing you
have to realize is that you do it
almost every day you will tell
somebody something about your life what
happened to you in the morning
what happened to you yesterday in other
words it's a primary way of connecting
with people is just to tell them
what happened in our lives even if
someone says how are you rather than
saying finds it i'm fine
except the other day this is what
happened and then you have a little bit
of your story
so the reason getting back to your
question the reason we tell people
stories about our lives are
multiple one is to connect
one is to be seen another is to actually
hide you can tell a story from your life
and hide
an aspect of yourself or the truth about
yourself
by telling another story you can tell a
story in your life to avoid
what the conversation is about you can
tell a story in your life to get
attention to feel important
you can tell a story a part of the story
of your life to
actually feel vulnerable and to get
sympathy or empathy
so there's a long wide range of reasons
we
sometimes intuitively instinctively
tell the stories from our life that tell
what's going on
in fact just before this interview i
won't go into them but
all of us the four of us here were
telling stories
about our lives and what we've been
through and what we're doing and all of
that
and we did this happens all the time
but then you have to look at if you are
intentionally
telling a story there's a story you were
going to intentionally tell
to one person to a group of people to
100 people a thousand people
now you have to think about your
question
actually karen why why am i telling
this story now if you want to tell a
story and the story is
fiction you also have to ask yourself
why am i telling this story but at the
same time you're also
making up a story you're creating a
story so there are two aspects
of it why am i telling it which will
affect what the story
is and how i'm going to write it but in
autobiographical stories that doesn't
happen
because there's something unique about
an autobiographical stories like the
ones you and i were discussing earlier
they have already been written
because they have already happened
there's nothing to
create the events you told the events i
told earlier
those have happened now you look at the
story and there is a
few big questions i want to tell this
story
the first thing is you have way more
information than you need you have all
the details of the story whatever the
event
was everything that happened everything
that happened to you around you what
other people did what other people said
whatever that event was there's way more
information
than you probably want to tell or could
include
so it's more now like making a
documentary film you have all this
footage
and you want to extract from that
a smaller story so now you have an event
what am i going to actually tell but
then you have to ask yourself
why am i telling this story and this is
where a lot of people struggle now elsia
and i
when we're teaching our workshop on
autobiographical storytelling called
write your life
one of the big things we deal with will
have anywhere from six
to 15 students each of them has an
autobiographical story that they've
already written just a three minute
story
and it's really interesting that a lot
of them have no idea which is totally
understandable
why they picked that story they picked
the story on their own
we just say pick an event and they are
not clear why and that's fine
there's no problem with that that's very
normal i don't know why so now
part of the struggle is to explore
yourself and explore
your experiences and to learn while
you're working on the story
learn about the story learn about
yourself and eventually learn
why you picked that story and there are
some people we've worked with when they
start to realize
why they really picked that story
sometimes they're horrified
oh i didn't want to do that i didn't
want to reveal that
and all i could say is well you picked
the story
and they realized they did that there's
something
inside going on and my belief is that
with autobiographical storytelling
there's an
inner voice that's even helping you pick
the story
so if you're going to meet with somebody
maybe for a job or a date or whatever
and you want to tell them something
about yourself and say oh i know what
i'll do i'll tell
him or her this story about what
happened to me because it's really a
great story
do you know why you picked that story
are you clear
and this all comes way before
the question of how do you want the
listener to receive the story
what do you want the listener to get
from the story
how do you want the listener to see you
as the storyteller or even to see you
as the person in the story and all of
that
is open and all of that is malleable
even without
changing the story so the question now
becomes
how do i tell the story so that i can
project myself present myself the way i
want to
and how can i tell it so that the
listener will receive the story the way
i want them to receive it do you think
people
change their story and it's not by
maybe just by omission by the way
they're reading the room
maybe they can tell either the room is
welcoming or maybe it's not so welcoming
so they don't feel comfortable sharing
certain aspects of their lives because
they can
there's a there's an elephant in the
room they're not sure what it is
but then they leave out certain details
because they don't want to offend
or or maybe they realize it won't be met
with the same reception as if they were
in another
setting yes now your question karen was
about do they change it
i mean in the process of telling it or
now are you talking about a stage
presentation like a solo show or
something like that or a speech
or a ted talk um it's possible
it's very very very possible it's very
possible
with the most skilled storytellers they
can change it in a heartbeat because
they can
tell a part of the story and get a
reaction that tells them okay i need to
make a
shift i need to make an adjustment and
go in a different direction because
that's
being received negatively or being
misinterpreted
and so i'm going to have to clear that
up and i'll shift sometimes shift to
another story
or tell the story in a different way or
reveal
something different within the story
than i had attended i had intended to
reveal this aspect of my character
or my experience in the story i'm going
to shift that to something else
and they can do it within the telling of
the story
i have one small story not an
autobiographical story but
i was uh working actually with val
kilmer
many years ago on his portrayal of um
mark twain now he's not doing an
autobiographical piece at all but he's
doing mark twain
telling mark twain stories so it's mark
twain telling stories
and we were talking a lot about hal
holbrook who he admired a lot who
has a whole career doing mark twain and
one thing i didn't know that bell told
me was that
mark twain had 17
different shows he could do all
mark twain material that he had
researched and
explored and so much material about mark
twain
that and he would get a booking he would
say okay you're going to do this in
we want to you perform in new york and
based on the fact that it's new york he
would
select certain material you're going to
do in new york for this
organization aha he'd do research on the
organization and from all the wide range
of material he would have
he would construct a different show
specifically for them if he was doing
the south it was a whole different show
so i think the the whole thing of
autobiographical storytelling i think by
instinct when we're just having a
conversation like you and i are
and we're telling the story by instinct
we will change
if we're not getting the reaction we
want we will shift
i know there are times i've started to
tell a story in a group and a
story and it got a little interrupted at
one point and
this happened to me just a few weeks ago
and i went
that's it my story's done i know
there's no point in finishing the story
i could feel that the energy and the
interest of the people with somewhere
else
and there was no point so i just stopped
so you can do that so i think there is
um
that's very important it's a great
question because we are telling our own
stories we're actually revealing
something about ourselves rather than
someone asking me what's your screenplay
about and i tell them that story well
that's not an autobiographical story at
all that's
a fiction story and i'll stick to
whatever the story is and hope that they
like it
but i'm telling an autobiographical
story i'm actually revealing bits and
pieces of me
one little piece after another after
another after another
and i know the times that i've done some
rather long stories
totally improvised long autobiographical
stories
about my experiences in hollywood and
things like that
and it's been a speech that i've agreed
to do i
will shift and change the tone of it
even based on the reactions and
sometimes the reaction is i'll say
something and i hear a reaction that i
wasn't expecting which means
they know exactly what i'm saying this
is a you know it's an inside joke they
got it okay then i will keep going in
that direction
because that is supporting what i want
to reveal
do you think they are regional
autobiographical stories
so let's say someone in la may tell
an autobiographical story that's more
career-based
whereas in some small town in another
part of the u.s
it might be more about their family and
how long their families
had the land or something i don't know
i'm just generalizing here but
i was wondering is is autobiograph
autobiographical storytelling more
regional based
in total in terms of the people who act
now you're talking about who are doing
it more or less professionally
you mean um i guess in what we select to
reveal
or leave out well again i'm going to
take your two example you have the la
story which you said is career-based or
industry-based or whatever
and somewhere in the midwest it's more
about family
my belief is and i'm pretty sure i might
the audience in la would rather hear the
family story
the audience in the midwest would rather
hear the the industry story
in other words because the the
to do a story a lot of stories about the
industry in l.a we go
i've heard that i've heard i lived that
you know that's nothing new but for
someone to be telling about being raised
in arkansas
you know and working on a farm like i
want to hear that because that
is not part of my experience i want that
experience i want to learn from that
so again that's judging the audience
assessing the audience and
will what i am talking about
resonate with them in some way or will
it
offend them in some way if you do a
one-person show in l.a about the
struggles of becoming a
famous actress most people won't go
i think we i know that we know that
story
we've heard that story so many times
well judy
the movie judy though because you're
seeing another side of it which is
another side the happy-go-lucky side of
what
most people probably want to project
yeah they'll go for that one
you know but i think that's because that
person's revealing you know renee
zellweger's character was
she was revealing these demons that we
don't always get
yeah and she's revealing the demons
within a very famous icon that we know
and so we want to know more and you're
right that film shows us
more about who judy really was and less
actually less about her career i mean
her career was in there
but it's more about the demons she was
struggling with
which is fascinating she did an
excellent job yeah
what makes a great story what makes a
great story
you know karen
that question is huge that's what drives
this entire industry
is what makes a great story i think a
couple of things
for me and it has to be personal because
i think different people have different
opinions of what is a great story or a
great film or whatever
but the great story is a story about a
very ordinary
human being who's faced with
extraordinary challenges
and goes through an extraordinary
transformation
trying to survive or get back to where
they were
or to find their way to some new place
so there's a journey
there's a great journey that that person
personally goes on
to me that that's what makes a great
story great story
to me is a story about relationships
about the struggle
uh this is obviously very personal
because this is my preference
the struggle in relationships not just
the struggle of the two individuals or
three or four individuals and trying to
achieve what they want to achieve
but the struggle we all have as human
beings just relating to
each other and being open with each
other being honest with each other
getting what we want from each other
giving what we want to each other
forming
some kind of relationship and how
difficult that is how perilous it is
how fragile it is and how quickly it can
fall apart
a good example of that is marriage story
which is not
which is like a beautiful wonderful
happy marriage which is falling apart
and sometimes at least my experience
watching that film
i'm going why why is it falling apart
well because it's that fragile and i
think that you know
there wasn't a big violation in the
middle of it that created this
falling apart those kind of stories
are what make for me
make great stories then in the story
telling the telling of the story
what makes a great story is when i'm
surprised
i love it when i'm surprised when
there's a point where the story's going
on
and what we all do when we see
a story happening is we all in our minds
consciously or unconsciously
anticipate or predict where it's going
to go
i can see where this is going to go or
this is going to happen or
because he did that she's going to do oh
i can see it and
many times we're right but then there
are those moments when it just does a
total reversal and we didn't see it
coming we didn't see it coming and what
that does
those moments those turning points that
are so startling
understandable but startlingly just are
not expected
and then they're not magical it's not
science fiction or anything like that
it's just not expected
that moment opens up something for us
and where we can see
deeper into who those characters really
are so we get greater insight into these
characters and their struggles and their
problems
and that's the beauty of a well told
story
why do you think some people resonate
with one story over another
so someone could see what we sound like
we both saw judy we both liked it
i thought it was was excellent as tragic
as it was
but some other people could see it and
say
i'm not impressed why do you think one
person thinks a story is great versus
another season says nothing special i
think it all comes to
and else and i have had this a couple of
times so i will sit
side by side at a movie and
elsa who's right over here elsa
will love the movie and i don't or vice
versa
now it's only because we're two
different people that it doesn't
it's still the same it's still the same
movie still the same story but getting
back to your question why what makes why
do people
resonate with certain stories i think it
all comes down to
projection because as we're watching a
story
one thing i'm very keenly aware of for
myself and for everybody else when we
watch a story we project ourselves into
the other characters
in fact and we do it when we read a
script or read a novel
we do the same thing but when we watch a
movie we do the same we project
ourselves and the way we
participate in the portrayal of that
character we get
involved with that character we care we
have empathy or we have disgust we have
some kind of
emotional connection with each character
and so we
go on the journey with them now if we
watch a movie like judy
and someone watches that and there's no
way for that
individual who's watching it to project
himself or herself into that character
because there's no common ground
there's nothing not that you have to be
an actress or a singer or in hollywood
but do you aspire to do anything
artistic do you have
you know these demons that is there
anything within
if there's nothing within that character
that they can project themselves into
and attach themselves to
then they're not going to like the film
because it
is not speaking to them nothing wrong
with the film
it just doesn't speak to them and they
could like another film
like a transformer film which they think
is brilliant and i could go
i don't get it because that i can't
project myself
into that world so there's a world and
there are characters that we have to
project
ourselves into and get involved and
engaged with
and if we can't then we'll just sit back
and watch the movie
and wonder what the whole fuss is all
about
you are now working on something called
the travis technique for
autobiographical storytelling
yes that's a long title what is it about
what is it about well it's um it's about
autobiographical storytelling
obviously and where it comes from
i have to go back and give you a little
history of this because
you made it sound like we're just
starting this this has been going on for
about 30 years
and about 30 years ago through
circumstance i got involved with helping
develop
and directing a one-person show with
paul
link which became time flies when you're
alive
that story which became a stage play
was the story of paul's wife who got
breast cancer and eventually died from
breast cancer and it was the story of
that whole journey that he went on with
his wife and his children
while she was fighting breast cancer and
without going into more detail
because there's a lot of detail though
it's a very powerful story it's a very
powerful love story it's a
it's a very sad story it's a very tragic
story it's a very heroic story
and paul was a friend of mine and i knew
francesca and when he said he wanted to
write a play because he and i and
another friend of ours dennis redfield
had created several plays together that
we had done
he said he wanted to create a play about
their life together and her death
at home because she refused to go to
hospitals and stuff like that
and i remember saying to her this was
only a week after she died i remember
saying to him
fine okay but let's talk about it later
let's talk about it after the memorial
service the memorial service for
francesca was going to be in a few days
it was actually at john ritter's home in
brentwood we were all there it was a
beautiful
out on the back lawn you could see the
mountains
and a lot of white balloons you can
imagine the white piano people played
music people read poetry it's very sad
but it's all this tribute to francesca
and then paul
was going to speak last and paul with
their one-year-old child she had a child
while she was fighting cancer
which is a big part of the story but
that rosie that one-year-old child
in his arm he got up and started to talk
and he's the first thing he says is i
want to tell you about my best friend
and within a few minutes he had
everybody there laughing
as he was telling this story and i'm
watching him and i'm going oh my god
this is amazing
and afterwards i talked to him and i
said paul
we're going to do the play but not the
play you thought you were going to do
he said what do you mean i said we're
not going to do this play of all these
characters
i said it has to be a one-man show it
has to be just
you telling your story i wanted to take
what i had seen there
and put that essence of paul and his
vulnerability and his openness and his
honesty and his transparency
on stage because i said that's the only
way this is going to work
we worked on it for about a year we did
a lot of research
we even talked to spaulding gray we're
doing a lot of things i've developed
this is the first time i'd ever done
this
after that was done i said to myself
and it was very successful ran for a
year in los angeles sold out
at the tiffany theater it was a sort of
a weird situation
but i said i'm done
i said i i can't do this again it's
exhausting
working on one with one person on one
show but it was it was a beautiful
experience
until i was at an acting class and i
heard another monologue
this man got up and he told a story
about
when his mother he did this monologue
about from some play
i thought about his mother picking up
after school taking him 350 miles away
from their hometown putting him in a
motel
and leaving him there at the age of 10
for the summer and he told the story and
i went oh my god i said afterwards i
said shane where you know where'd that
story come from i mean
what what's that from it's amazing
because i thought it was from a script
he said that's from my life
and i remember that feeling at that
moment going
oh my god i've got another one now this
kept happening i kept getting
people would start coming to me and we
did that that show which was called no
place like home which was all about
child abuse that's why she took
him there to save him from her the
father
who was intent on killing the son
she saved his life so
that was a whole show about child abuse
and then came a bronx tale which i
developed with
chaz palm and terry and that became so
suddenly all these
shows became big hits and people said
coming to me but it wasn't
the fact that people were coming to me
what
my tendency i have to tell you a little
story
when i was a young boy i was very good
at fixing things
taking things apart and fixing things i
loved doing that
and my father had an old watch
a pocket watch which didn't work and i
asked him if i could take it up it
wasn't valuable
at all and i asked him if i could take
it apart he said sure
so i took the whole thing apart and put
because i was
curious to figure out how it worked and
i got it all back together again it
still didn't work but it was all back
together again
the reason i tell you that is this is
the way my mind works
i'm less interested in the final product
of what i create
than i am and how it's created
so i did a lot of research while i was
developing all these one-person shows on
what how does this process really work
what are the techniques that work why
did this work in this
with this show and not with this show or
why all of these things
and from that long period of time which
started back in the early 90s
a long period of time up until to now
we're still doing this
exploring this whole aspect of
autobiographical storytelling
why is it so powerful and what are all
the tools and the techniques that you
can use in the telling of any story
that will change and alter and enhance
or mold the story in the way you want to
so that has led to but again back in the
90s someone asked me to teach a workshop
on what i was doing this is
after i'd had several very successful
shows
and i said i couldn't i said i can't i
said it's just one on one i work with
the actor
we worked together we developed the show
that's it
and then that person did something which
is
totally unforgivable offered me a lot of
money to teach the workshop
and i went no now maybe i can do it so i
agreed to do it and i started a workshop
and that's when i started to realize i
can teach this
there is a lot of stuff i do know and so
this has become
now this workshop which at that time was
called the solo workshop because it was
mostly for solo performers
now it has morphed into being called the
write your life workshop because it's
not
for solo i mean it's for everybody it's
for solo performers
for writers memoirists screenwriters any
any storyteller so we have storytellers
from all over the world
who want to take this workshop
because it's so powerful not because
they want
interesting not because they want to
learn how to
tell autobiographical stories they want
to
learn the basics and the sort of the
core and the foundation of storytelling
because when when like screenwriters
take this
course they suddenly their screenwriting
improves
so it's a foundation so when it says the
travis technique for autobiographical
storytelling
this right to life is the foundation of
everything else and i teach
not just the writing but the directing
and acting and working with that it all
comes out of that so when people come to
study with us
the first thing they do is
write autobiographical story and go
through that process
it's like learning the scales before you
start to try to play
classical music or something else
what if someone says well i'm not a
writer and i'm not
i'm not planning on doing a one-woman
show
why would i need to to learn how to tell
my own story
where are opportunities that we have
this in our daily lives we don't even
realize it
in our daily lives now i'm assuming this
person that you're
throwing at me uh is a writer or just
just just an
average maybe they're an insurance
adjuster oh insurance address and and
they say
what do i convince me why should i take
a class to learn how to tell my personal
story
and i would go back this is going back
to some of our first questions some of
your first questions i would say to that
person okay
um you're an insurance adjuster you're
working with people and clients and
all the time yeah when's the last time
you told one of them
a personal story
when's all that and why were you telling
that story
and did you get the res the
result that you wanted did you
communicate what you really
wanted to and were you even aware of
what you were trying to communicate
and if you were aware of what you're
trying to communicate do you know there
were probably
several a dozen different ways you could
have told that story
to get the result you wanted
in other words i'm just saying that in
your work and your life
you frequently tell a personal story
you go to a family reunion and suddenly
people are telling stories and you have
a story to tell
do you want to tell it consciously or
unconsciously
do you want to be aware mindful of what
you're doing and how you want to
impact other people how you want to be
seen
what you want them to think
so the interesting thing about
storytelling
people people say well i'm a storyteller
i'm a screenwriter i'm a storyteller i'm
a storyteller
who isn't who doesn't
tell stories my
serious belief with the children before
they can speak
all that little those little noises
they're making
they're telling a story in their mind
they're telling a story
they are communicating something
eventually they get language and
eventually they get words and then
stories come out
so even if you if you have a little
three-year-olds or four-year-olds
who can be very verbal two-year-olds can
be very just listen to them their
stories just
start tumbling out of them
it's a huge part of who we are
in fact i think you know storytelling is
right up there with breathing
we do it all the time unconsciously we
need it
on i'm not even knowing why we don't get
go through the day
re reminding ourselves to breathe we
just
do it we don't go through say oh i think
i should tell a story we just
do it and then there's another part of
like write your life
which is very important which is do you
know how to listen to a story
do you know how to hear a story and so
when someone's telling you a story
can you listen listen for the story and
listen for what's really going on can
you see beyond
what they're really saying to see deeper
into the story so there's that
that aspect of it too so that insurance
sales person could benefit enormously
what if someone says well how can i tell
people about myself but i don't want to
tell them certain things
then don't tell them those certain
things in fact don't pick those stories
pick it pick a different story um
yeah there are a lot of people who are
afraid to tell stories because they were
afraid of what they're going to reveal
but then this is a a big aspect a part
of the write your life
process is we ask we don't ask for the
answers to this question
we ask everybody like i could ask you
karen
right go ahead um
if you had no fear okay
if there was no fear what story would
you tell
right now on camera
you can say it on camera it's your
camera
if there was no fear right
i know a few you know a few okay
absolutely
yeah even even that you know in the
workshop even that even
people in the workshop thinking about
the important thing of that question is
not the story you come up with important
about that question is the realization
that
my fear of that story is what's stopping
me
the fear is the important part not the
story
true and then this has happened many
many times in the workshops
one little thing about the write your
life workshop
which i'm very proud i was back in 2001
i was asked to teach it in hawaii
and i taught a weekend workshop there
and then eventually became two weekends
because it became so popular two
consecutive weekends this is where i met
elsa
because she would she was a student back
in 2002
but and that workshop went on for 16
years
up until 2015. anyway i went on for 16
and the thing is there were times when
we would bring up like
you know if you had no fear what story
would you tell
and people go oh yeah now a lot of
people who took the workshop
would take it every year which was great
they would come back every year because
they
not because again getting back to your
other question not because they're going
to do a one one-person show
not because they're going to write the
stories they did it because they like
the process of exploring themselves
through these their stories and hearing
their friends
explore themselves and expose themselves
through their stories
and many times we would bring up that
question if you had no fear what would
you
what story would you tell and people go
yeah i know and we ask them to write it
down they write it down we don't ask
them to share it
and many times two or three years later
someone would tell a story
they would say that was the story i
wrote down years ago
that i was afraid to tell and we go wow
something happens now this is a very
important part of autobiographical
storytelling in
one show that i did this is where it
became really clear this is the one on
child abuse
and shane mccabe who is brilliant
performer
told me this story a little story within
the big story
and the little story was about him
living in his
bedroom where he was forced to sleep in
the closet
and because his his house was built by
his father and
it wasn't built that well there were a
lot of openings and places and he's in
the closet and this little squirrel
showed up in the closet and over a long
period of
weeks and weeks and weeks he started to
develop
a relationship with this squirrel
okay and it's a beautiful story and how
the squirrel will adventure eat out of
his hands and how the squirrel when
he could get sneak out of the closet and
sleep in the bed the squirrel would
sleep with him wherever
they would sleep together now it has a
very tragic ending which i'm not going
to tell you
horrible ending but as shane
is telling me this story he said mark
i'm going to tell you a story but
it's not going in the show
he says i want to tell you the story
about chipper because he kept mentioning
chipper and i didn't know who chipper
was so he tells me about chipper the
squirrel
this horrendous story now me
being a storyteller and me being a
director i hear that story go oh this is
good
this has to go in the show and he's
going it's not going in the show i'm not
going to tell that story
and i could see why because he was so
devastated
he could barely hold himself together
while he was telling it and you don't
want that
on stage and he doesn't want that and we
kept working on the show
developing and developing every once in
a while chipper would come up i would
mention chipper he wouldn't mention
chipper
and then one day he said to me
maybe the chipper's story should go in
the show i said really
i said and i would ask him to tell me
again and he would tell me the story
again
and then we tried we said okay let's put
it in there we'll rehearse it we'll try
it and we did
and he kept telling it and telling it
telling it the key thing was i remember
on
opening night we're at the tiffany
theater in los angeles
he's opening in front of 100 strangers
and he's
on stage telling that story and he's
fine he's totally he has it all under
control
and what became clear to me was these
stories that are so traumatic
and so awful that we are so afraid if we
tell them probably afraid that we're
going to die
we'll never recover we'll lose all
self-esteem
or whatever whatever's going to happen
it's just going to be
horrendous or people are going to find
out about it
and and i can't live with that whatever
the fears
are if you keep telling the story
and this is my way of looking at it it's
not that the fears go away
but the power shifts as a ship the story
is here
and you're here this story has power
over you
and it keeps and it keeps it suppressed
but if you keep telling the story
what happens is it shifts and eventually
you have power over the story same story
same dramatic intent same trauma
everything but you have power over the
story
and elsa and i have seen this so many
times when people have
suddenly found somewhere the courage or
the strength to tell something that they
thought they could
never tell and so this process
is also a healing process not intended
not designed to do that but it doesn't
how does knowing our own story make us a
better storyteller
that's a big question that's a great
question because that's at the core
of everything let's say karen you have
an
autobiographical story a story you want
to tell
and a couple of things a couple of
things are very clear
one thing i mentioned earlier is it's
already written
so the question is how to tell the story
not what the story is but how do i tell
it
another thing that's very very clear
getting in terms of writing and getting
in terms
of how this process will
influence your writing of anything
is the protagonist the protagonist
in your story is you and let's say it's
a story when you were 15 years old and
a date you had or something like that
whatever it is i can see you
trying to remember one yeah which one
which was sitting
alone waiting by the phone that's what
it was okay okay it's a story of you
sitting home and
that's fine now you but you're the
protagonist of the story
of any story now the question is when
you think about we talk to writers about
the stories that they're creating and
writing
how well do they know the protagonist
now this is often a
problem um with a lot of the people who
teach
screenwriting or storytelling you know
how well do you know the protagonist how
well do you even know
your own characters but now we're back
to autobiographical
the protagonist is you you should know
you pretty well in fact you should know
the other people around you family and
friends or whoever
else is in that story pretty well this
is good
this is really good but the question is
your protagonist
how well let's say at 15 how well
do you know the 15 year old karen
how well do you know what she was really
thinking really feeling really wanting
really desiring really expecting really
fearing
at that time you know what you did you
know about sitting at the phone you know
that the phone didn't ring or it did
ring and it wasn't wasn't for you it was
for somebody else or whatever it was
you know what the you know what the
events of the story are
but here's something that's really
important
the events of your story karen about
sitting home
waiting by the phone those events and
what happened
is not the story
those are the events of the story that's
the plot
or that's the story line but it's not
the story
the story is what happens inside 15 year
old karen
what is going on inside this young woman
sitting there by the phone what is
really going on
what is she hoping for what is she
fearing who is she fearing that might
call
who is she hoping that might come that's
what we need to know
that's the story so the story exists
inside the protagonist
not around the protagonist now all the
events around the protagonists that
happen
actually trigger what's going on inside
or what's going on inside is a reaction
to
what's going on in the outside so we
need both but the events
are not the story the inner world
of 15 year old karen that is the story
so now in this process and now right now
on camera i'm going to invite you to
come take you and david to come take a
right your life
workshop as our guest see that's on tape
so right now the process is karen
you have to look at 15 year old karen as
a character and go
who is she what's really going on
and then once you can determine i know
what was going on i remember this is
what was going on this was going on
now and you have all of that that was
going on during this
event now the next question is
how do i relate that to the audience
how do i let the audience know that
there's that one guy
charlie and i'm hoping he won't call
because he did threaten to call
i'm hoping because if he calls and i
answer the phone i'm
in trouble because i don't know if i
have the courage to say no to him
and i don't want i'm just making this up
how are you going to let the
audience know that because if the
audience doesn't know that
if the audience in fact doesn't know
what's going on inside you
they don't get the story all they get is
events they go fine you're sitting at
home and then you're worried and
you can say i was worried and all that
which gets us to the two narrators in a
second
here but but that's so learning how to
for the writers to go through the
process of exploring
excavating pulling apart looking at all
the elements of a story that they know
better than anybody else and exploring
really what was going on for them and
for all the people around them and then
to try to understand the other parent
the parents
the brothers and sisters or whoever the
other characters are understanding
them and how can i render them true to
who they are
that's what makes a difference in all
the other writing
because we say what else and i say to
people who have taken the rights your
life
especially writers and directors we say
okay now
you see how deeply you have gone into
your character and all the other
characters they go yeah yeah
you have to do that for every character
and everything you direct
and everything you write that's what you
have to do
and now the bar is really high but now
they understand
i have to understand my protagonist in
my fictional movie as well as i
understand me
but you can't do that until you've gone
through a process of understanding you
well you just triggered a memory and
that was i wasn't 15
but the age 15 came up and that was
being home
and there was a knock at the apartment
door my mom wasn't home i wasn't 15 i
was younger
and it was quote the paper boy coming to
collect
and i said well uh and i was stammering
he goes
if you're 15 i'll take you out
and i remember thinking wow like
like that's he doesn't even know who i
am on the other side i could see him
because
yeah but but it was i can still see that
because it was i don't think i was even
12 yet and he didn't know that
i sounded older than i was but just the
fact that somebody's coming to collect
for the paper
and he's already trying to like you know
hustle up a date or something it's just
kind of funny but so you reminded me of
that because he mentioned
if you're 15 because he said i'm 15. 15
if you're 15 i'll take you out even
though i can't see you
right and i'm here just to climb paper
boy i'm here to collect for your
for your paper but anyway but so so
going into that just reminds me so there
you go there's part of a story
no that's a good story it's a good story
and
on the surface like many most stories
we go oh that's cute it's kind of creepy
at the time yeah
no yeah but it was creepy to you right
right
to the rest of the world you say you
know there i am and he says you're 15
i'll take it oh my god
okay what we do once we start to hear
what's going on inside you
you know that feeling like oh it's this
you know i'm feeling uncomfortable or
that's what we want to hear that's what
that's the
richness that's the core of that's the
gold of the story
is what's going on inside that little 12
year old
right at that moment who's home alone
who's home alone and the paper boy
is is coming to collect yep
it's a great story thank you i can still
see it
what do you think most people go wrong
in telling their personal stories
too much information too little um
too much information or too little
possibly each but
um getting back to what we were talking
about
is yeah there could be too much
information
which about the events and all of that
which actually masks what's really going
on in the character
or they could be too little information
about
the character here's but here's the um
a real key many times when we're doing
these workshops or working with somebody
who's doing this kind of writing
um i will say quite honestly to them
it's a great story but you're not in it
and they'll go what do you mean no no i
was there and i told you i said no no
you were there you were the observer
the way you told the story you were the
observer
more like a journalist you were the
observer and you told us
all the details and you gave us a little
indication like oh yeah in that moment
when i was really scared or something
like that and i go okay
but the thing is you are not really in
the story you have kept yourself
out of the story now this story that
this person has told
quite possibly could be a very traumatic
story
frightening one of those stories that
generates a lot of fear
and now what can happen as a result of
telling a story like that
is as you're telling the story even
keeping yourself
some very much out of the story all
those fears will come back because there
you're
it's it's wired into your system
those fears and everything are in your
body and you are stimulating them again
and so you will feel the fear or feel
the joy
feel the confusion whatever as you're
telling the story
the problem is you will think that the
audience is feeling the same thing
and i can tell you right now they're not
they're not there's no reason for them
because they're not you
they will each member of the audience
will be feeling whatever they feel
they say oh that that's funny oh that's
that's kind of sad
there's a wide range of what they could
be feeling
i think autobiographical the goal of
autobiographical storytelling is can i
tell you a story
can i tell you a story like about my
10th birthday
in such a way that i can take you
through the story
and you are moment by moment feeling
and experiencing exactly what i felt as
the 10 year old at that moment
while the story is being told without
telling you oh in that moment i felt
really scared
then you now that's just a piece of
information that will not stimulate a
feeling within you my job as the
storyteller is to stimulate emotion
within you
not just give you information so this
when you ask about too much information
too
little information it's usually too
little of the
real meat that we want which is what is
going on inside the character i want to
know what you're thinking or feeling
most people won't do that they just want
by instinct they won't do that
it's sort of a preservation instinct so
then we will listen to the story and
we'll have our
own reaction to it
based on our life experience that's it
which
we got to which we talked about with why
people like certain films and certain
stories
now you could tell a story to a group of
a dozen people
without having yourself really present
in the story
and those dozen people will have about a
dozen different reactions to the story
based on
their life experience as if if this had
happened to them
this is how they would respond but the
more powerful story is they
know exactly how you were feeling how
you were responding
and now they're not responding to just
the story
they're responding to your experience
your emotional experience through the
story and that's much more powerful
was there a story that had power over
you
that then you were able to tell so many
times and then you switched it and now
you had power over that story that was
your story
well you know in the 30 years of doing
this
is that what you mean whenever yeah
yes i mean i've been doing this for 30
years
and one um it's a great question karen
and
one thing i realized very early on when
i started to
work either with individual performers
doing solo shows
or work with a group like a workshop or
even a larger group
what i was asking all of those writers
or those artists or those human beings
those people
to do was dig into their past
have a story and start to really explore
it in a very open
raw vulnerable way and in order to
really ask them to
take those that leap
the best way i could um help them do
that was to tell my own stories
so i would always in every workshop tell
a story
or be or tell several stories to give
them examples not only of how the story
works or how the storytelling techniques
which i was trying to teach them work
but it's that simple thing
and this has to do with directing don't
ask an actor to do something that you're
not willing to do yourself
so i couldn't ask these people to write
something that i wasn't willing to do so
i need to do it
and do it in front of them and many
times during that
i would
[Music]
purposely set myself a high challenge
just in terms of the story that i would
pick
or the what i was going to talk about i
would push myself
to say can i go a little bit further can
i go a lit
can i get into a more dangerous area
and there was one time and elsa was
there that i told the story
in hawaii that it happened just two
weeks earlier
which was devastating to me it was a
devastating story
and it was humiliating and brought a lot
of shame
to me and embarrassment and i'd only
told one person about it my sister who
was also in the workshop at that time
and but basically i was hiding it from
the rest of the world and then i decided
in that workshop i was going to tell a
part of that story
and i did and it was a struggle it was
hard
but it was liberating and um
so yes that's you know i've had that
experience many times
going wow now i've done that i can i can
do it again so that
my assessment that telling tough stories
traumatic stories embarrassing or
shameful stories
again and again and again the balance
will change
i've also experienced that within my own
storytelling
have you seen or some people have
they're just
unabashedly open about everything i mean
they're just people that
i'm just shocked they would put
something on twitter but that's just who
they are
as human beings there's no shame in
anything everything's an open book
maybe they came from a family that's
like that and so that's how they
communicated
whereas there's other people that
they're afraid to tell you what they had
for breakfast
right and they're super reserved and you
feel like
every question you ask even about the
weather is somehow a personal intrusion
do you see those people interacting at
your workshop together and just
just you know the ones with the arms
cross where it's not even that they
they don't like somebody but there's
just that's
who they are they're just maybe not as
trusting and other people that
they'll tell the cashier at the store
some intimate detail from their love
life yeah i mean the thing is in the
workshops we get
a whole range of people and it's
interesting because they
they just using your two examples the
one who is just
the ones who just will blurt out
anything personal
and the other ones who are much more
reserved and are afraid to even tell you
their birthday or whatever whatever it
is
we get that range definitely that range
the first thing that's really
interesting is
at the beginning of the workshop what we
do is we check in with each person
in front of everybody not not privately
why they're there
what they what they really want and just
sometimes hearing
what they want is interesting and very
quickly we get a sense of the
personality
and maybe elsa and i have talked to this
person beforehand or met them
online or something so we have a sense
of who they are before they
come into the workshop but we we check
in with them to see
what their goals are and we get a sense
that this one is very
reserved and this let's say this woman
is so reserved and as you said sort of
like that that's not going to talk about
anything and
we just say well i know why she's here
and but then we have a feeling this is
gonna this workshop is gonna be
tough for her or a shock for her and
sometimes
that person will by the end of the three
days
because it's just a three-day workshop
will explode
and something will come out and
sometimes my feeling
is they're there unconsciously because
they want to release
now on the other end the ones who will
expl um
say everything expose everything we have
to watch them carefully too
because they can take over we have
people who come in
and want to show us how it's done
and we know they're going to run into a
shock but when we start
talking to them about some of the things
i've talked to you about they go what
do you mean i don't know myself and
there's another part of this which we
can talk you and i can talk about today
about
how we use interrogation in this process
but because we interrogate that person
if i were to interrogate you
as the 12 year old the one that answered
the door for one picture of the door
so this woman over here is telling a
story about herself and whatever and
then we interrogate her at that time
now suddenly she's aware that she has
she's
not as free as she thought she was
then there's and that person will go
most likely go through a change during
the three days
and there's another huge part of this
workshop
is that it's a workshop there are maybe
a dozen people there
and every single person is working on an
autobiographical story
every single person is struggling with
their own obstacles their own
resistance their own self-esteem
whatever it is they're struggling with
this so you're in a room
that is really rather unique the energy
in the room is extraordinary
so that shy one who won't say anything
is being encouraged by the ones others
that she sees
who are struggling who make
breakthroughs
the the one who thinks she knows and
everything is also going to benefit by
experiencing what the other ones are
going through
so that's a big part of the workshop is
just to be in that environment
for those three days and be immersed
in that world of autobiographical
storytelling and struggling with your
own story
writing your story rewriting your story
listening to other people seeing them
make breakthroughs
seeing them not make breakthroughs and
not be able to get through an obstacle
and seeing how frightening that is
all of that impacts everybody so the
truth is when else and i do these
workshops
we have no idea what's going to happen
we do the workshop pretty much the same
way every time
but then after it's all over elsa and i
sit down and discuss could we
improve how can we change what new
things can we try and we come up with
some new
things but pretty much generally it's
the same thing it's the environment that
the people are plunged into
that causes the change interesting so
the extrovert that is is a
free spirit and tells everybody
everything can learn from the reserved
introverted arms crossed and vice versa
yes
yes and the extrovert may learn very
graphically or just very subtly
that her explosion of stories that she
puts out is actually covering up
the story she's not revealing
anything except an ego
is it a defense mechanism though right
could be
i'm just saying could be i don't know it
depends on the person
but i'm going to tell you this and i'm
going to tell you that and do you
remember the the
the film american beauty yes remember
angela
the the little cheerleader oh yes who
was just talking about her sexual
exploits forever and ever and ever and
ever and ever
until the end when she said this is my
first well that was a cover-up
those stories the stories she was
telling was a cover-up for her
insecurities that she
is as she said ordinary she was afraid
of just being ordinary that nobody would
want her
so she creates this whole myth about
everybody wants her
right in wes bentley who is a drug
dealer i guess in the uh
kind of almost downplays his
intelligence
in a way and you don't realize how deep
and like feeling
he is but i don't know it's been a while
since i've seen it but i love it
yeah so i mean that's just an example so
yeah the extrovert
and the introvert will learn from other
and they and the
the extent of what they learn may not
resonate within them until weeks or
months later
because of this experience they may
start to see things differently they may
start to tell their stories differently
who knows
it's very powerful and it it is a
healing process
and the first workshops i did in hawaii
the first few years
there was a married couple um i think it
was mary and john i think that's that's
their name
anyway and they took it for several
years very couple
they were very unique only in one way
they would each have their story they
were going to tell and as
we learned quickly after the first year
or so
that john would start telling the story
and the thing was watch
mary because mary has probably never
heard this story before
they would each tell stories in the
workshop that they had never
told each other before and by the end of
several years the last time i saw them
they said that workshop
made such a difference in their marriage
you know because it gave them a safe
place to be more open and
more available and more transparent
how does someone decide where to start
their story
wow that's how does where to start the
story
now i'm assuming we have this little
three or four or five minute story
right so a little i'm staying with us
you mean where to start that story
well if they're going to tell people
their life
what if they don't want to say well at
all you know i was raised in such and
such a town
what if they want to start it from the
time that they left college
okay because they feel like that's when
they're real self-beginners
okay we need we need to talk about two
things then now i understand more
we need to un talk about uh sequencing
okay sequencing of information which i
can talk about
which has to do with the events in a
story
and do you really want to start with the
beginning of the story do you want to
start with something in the middle in
other words playing with the sequence
the chronology of events
as you tell the story so that's one
thing the the other thing we can talk
about when you say
tell the story of my life
there's another topic and which i'm
willing to
forget what we're shooting now but
another topic which is about
how an autobiographical story is
put together because it's put together
differently than a screenplay
it's put together differently than
novels put that together differently
than
fiction and how we
the process i use to explore what the
story is really about
through the writing and don't make a
determination at the beginning
so those are two types that make sense
so sequencing
and then sequencing and then structuring
the autobiographical story okay
which are two different things the
structuring is which story
comes first and the sequence of stories
and then there's the sequencing within a
story
so is that something you would determine
if someone presents you
i'm sorry i'm not it presents me what
so when you work with someone how do
they decide
where to begin okay let's talk about how
to where to begin with just
one little story someone has told
a story and i'm not i'm just going to go
back to your
you know can we my life is very dull
yeah i'm not really interested in
talking about me sorry
why don't we do a hypothetical uh
version of karen who's much more
exciting
a hypothetical that's fiction that's
fiction
okay karen who's had an amazing
wild incredible life okay i'm going to
tell you a quick story right now
one of my stories and we'll use that we
will use that as an example
okay and i'll tell you just just give
you an overview of the story
this is when i was uh nine years old
about to become
10 years old and so i was about to have
my 10th birthday i have an older brother
an older sister and i have younger
siblings too
but my parents always made the 10th
birthday a special birthday special gift
extraordinary so as i'm approaching as i
was approaching
my 10th birthday i was very excited
about
what's my gift going to be i had seen
what my older brother peter got it was
great at least he thought it was great
but it was great and it was very
expensive
and i saw what my sister got she thought
it was great they were very happy and so
i wanted something that was equally as
great or
actually better i thought mine should be
better
and so i was waiting for that
moment and then comes the morning of my
birthday
and i'm waking up i can barely sleep i'm
waking up i can't wait
until the we get to the the time of the
day when i'm going to open the presents
and all of that
and my father is saying happy birthday
and i'm thinking that
well it's a special gift i think it
might be it could be a bike i'm hoping
it's going to be a bike
or i'm i was hoping that it could be
maybe something like skates
ice skating because i was into ice
skating and i also wanted
maybe some new skis something like that
bicycle skate skis that would have been
great
and i was just sitting there wondering
what it's going to be
and then the time came when we're
opening the gifts and
the whole family is around my older
brother and sister and the younger ones
are there
and when they were there and when i
opened
the gift i don't even know if you'll
know what this is when i tell you
when i opened the gift what was inside
was a wooden press
to keep a tennis racket from warping
now i played tennis i knew what this
was i had a tennis racket
in fact a new tennis racket might have
been nice but why did i need a new press
because there were wooden tennis
racquets
back then and i was just devastated
and disappointed and my father seemed
very pleased and my mother seemed very
pleased
but my brother seemed smug peter right
peter yeah and faith seemed not terribly
interested
so i didn't get what i wanted why do you
think they gave you that
because they i don't know is it what it
represented to you that you weren't
what my yeah i think what that story is
really about
karen is um as the third child
in a family of six children
i really felt
less than most of the other children
except maybe my youngest sister but
anyway
the last the sixth one and at that time
at 10 years old
i think what i really wanted to feel
i wanted to feel is that i was as
special if
not more special than my older brother
and sister and this 10th birthday gift
would do it
and only once would you get to do this
and i know what they got
and i know and then i saw what i got and
it just didn't do it
so my expectation is that after that i
get the gift
my self-esteem would be super high i
would feel proud of myself i would feel
important but i didn't
okay now getting back to sequencing
a story right
the question is with that story where do
you start
now the story and you know this from
filmmaking to
the story could start at the moment of
opening the gift
say what would happen i could this is
what i'll we'll do with students a lot
of time what would happen if you start
with the opening of the gift
well then i said yeah but no but you
don't reveal what the gift is you
you start at the moment of the opening
again the moment when the
adrenaline is so high and the
anticipation is so
huge and you start then and then you go
back to
the beg to the beginning and start that
way what happens if you
tell the story out of order the
important thing is that by the time the
story is told
completely the audience has all the
information that you're going to give
them that's it
but it doesn't mean they need it in
chronological
order in fact it could start
after the opening after
as i'm walking back to my room and i
could start
with the story talking about me walking
back to my room with
my gifts devastated destroyed
feeling despondent i feel like i want to
cry
it could start there and now if you
think about it if you start there the
audience is going what happened
what happened to you that was so awful
and you're carrying birthday gifts and
you want to cry
the audience has no frame of reference
to make sense out of that
which is great because it makes the
audience curious
then i can go back to the excitement
about what i'm going to get now the
audience knows the end
and they're trying to figure they're not
trying to figure out where it's going to
go
but they're telling me how did it get
from this to that
i could even throw in the middle of it
how much i love tennis
throughout the middle of the story so
that
the tennis the the press for the tennis
racket
the audience will think well that's
great but they realize it's not great
because it's not
greater than what peter and faith got
and where do i get that information in
so it's it's
it's not so that's a that's the
sequencing where are you going to start
where do you want to finish that's the
sequencing of a story
now this is actually a lot of the
um storytelling techniques that we teach
in write your life with autobiographical
stories
come from film
film editing now you've seen films that
start in the middle
you've seen events that start there
you've seen flashbacks you go what is
that
and all of that process
mark can you share with us your use of
two narrators
yes um these the story i just
told you about my uh 10th birthday
was told mostly in the past tense
now what we will do when someone says
asks you something and you're about to
tell
an autobiographical story or you want to
tell a story or you want to tell
someone about what you just witnessed or
you saw a week or two ago
you will by instinct there's a lot of
reasons for this tell it in the past
tense
you will say okay it was last wednesday
and i was driving my car
on the freeway and then i saw and it's
in the past tense now as soon as you are
telling the story in the past tense
the listener automatically knows
several things they know
that you know the ending of the story
now that sounds silly or maybe a little
confusing
why wouldn't you of course you do know
the ending but when you tell it in the
past tense
that narrator talking to past tense
knows the end of the story that narrator
also knows
everything that's happened since that
story until the present moment
that's why we call it the omniscient
narrator the narrator who knows
everything i know the story i'm going to
tell you i know how it
ends i know everything that's happened
since then i know the repercussions of
that story i know
everything so it actually means that in
the telling of the story the story is
like
here and the storyteller is here telling
about this thing and you the listener
are there and there's the story so the
story is separate
from me the storyteller and separate
from you
it's this entity that exists by itself
here
then there's another narrator the other
narrator is
is called the naive narrator
and this is the tricky one and very very
powerful
the naive narrator tells the story
in the present tense
tells the story not only just in the
present tense but is telling the story
from the point that the
character is in at the moment
not knowing even what's going to happen
in the next few
seconds so rather than in the past tense
okay it was last wednesday i was driving
my car on the 405.
that's the omniscient narrator the naive
narrator i'm driving my car
i'm on the 405. now it's in the present
tense now right then just the fact that
you hear it in the present tense
shifts the whole story because it sounds
like
i don't know what's going to happen i'm
driving on the 405
and i see this little yellow car and
it's zooming it's zooming up behind me i
can see it in my rear view mirror
now i can tell you all that you still
get the feeling that i don't
know what's going to happen although
of course if you're smart enough you'll
say well mark is telling me this story
he's here in front of me he must know
how it's going to end but my feeling is
he doesn't he doesn't because he's put
himself
in the middle of the story telling the
story as
it happens he is totally totally naive
now karen the story is not here with me
here
the story is around me and it's actually
around
you too you are in the middle of the
story
i'm in the middle of the story and quite
honestly that's where
you want to be now think about this
every screenplay that you've ever read
i'm assuming you've read a lot of them
they're all in the present tense they're
all
in the present tense jim does this he
does that he does this he does that
do you know why they're in the present
tense because when it's up on the screen
we want to believe it's happening as we
watch it now we as an audience of
film are smart enough to know
that we go to see a movie
we know they spent how many years
writing it how many
months shooting it how you know all the
work they've done it's done
it's finished but we go and we watch it
suspending disbelief and i'll believing
that that what we are watching right now
on the screen
is happening in the moment because
that's where we want to be
so the naive narrator
can take us into the center of the story
so as you're telling a story it's not
which narrator you use
it's when you use each narrator
that gives you control over the story
in other words i could be telling you
the story i'm making up this story about
the 405. it's just as good as anything
else
i'm driving on the 405. i'm a 405 and
i'm feeling nervous because behind me i
see in this rearview mirror this yellow
car is coming at me and he he or she or
whatever is going way too fast and i'm
really scared
now that's all the naive narrator
and you are probably in the point of
going what's going to happen what's
going to happen now i
as the storyteller and this is the
beauty of being a storyteller
i am in total control of this story
and i at any time i want can pop you out
of the story right now you're in the
middle of the story
i can pop you out at any time i want
and i can say the car is coming at me
it's coming faster and faster now you
got to understand something about me and
yellow cars
you know the first car i ever bought was
a yellow station wagon
it was really an ugly car now what i
just did is i
jumped to the other narrator
i jumped out of the story i jumped to
the other narrator i'm giving you some
information that i think you need to
have which will help inform the story
but i've left you hanging about what's
going on
in the story and there's a part of you
go okay great information but what's
happening there
okay i got it i got it now i have you
curious about two things why am i
getting this new information
and what's happening there and then any
moment i can see and
then i look in the rear view mirror and
it's coming closer and closer and closer
and i can see there's nobody driving it
there's nobody so i can switch back and
forth now
as i switch back and forth between those
two narrators i'm actually
manipulating you i'm bringing you
into the story pulling you out of the
story bring you into the story
pull you out of the story that's all
part of the structure of the story that
i want to tell that's how i want to tell
it
when playing with you and playing with
your relationship
to the story do we like being
manipulated
does the audience i mean i realize
that's a weird way to say it but does
that something we like
do you like roller coasters i don't you
don't but i like movies
but you like movies but i don't like
roller coasters okay but you did that so
that's why
um but i i think
there's sort of a wonderful love-hate
relationship with being manipulated
i don't want to be manipulated and then
we go through a movie oh
that's so scary wasn't that great and
i'm thinking well you were just
manipulated
i think we find our forms of
entertainment that manipulate us whether
it's roller coaster rides
or a movie that take us into
danger take us into a zone of danger
where we feel that we're at risk roller
coaster ride we could die
you feel that way sometimes in a movie
it's an emotional danger and i'm going
to feel sad i'm going to feel hurt i'm
going to feel scared
but then you can we come out going wow
that was great
i want to see that again but i said you
were scared you were screaming
out of fear so there's this curious
relationship we have
my feeling is when we go to see a movie
or we read a book or we
or hear a story being told is
please please manipulate me
thrill me scare me dazzle me my only
caveat is don't bore me
don't be boring i don't mind movies that
i hate
because i felt hate i hate this then i
hate these
i don't mind characters that i hate
people say wasn't that one i
hated her whatever it is it doesn't
matter
and all these characters and all these
stories they do manipulate us
but the worst thing is to go there's no
point to watching this there's nothing
going on this is just boring that's the
worst
how do most people use the naive
narrator
incorrectly and then the omniscient
narrator incorrectly several things
about the two narratives you need to
understand
and how they can be if they're used
incorrectly they just won't be effective
at all one thing about
the omniscient narrator the omniscient
narrator does
know everything the omniscient narrator
since the omniscient narrator is talking
about an event there and is
actually that narrator is not involved
in the event
that narrator is only telling about the
event
the mistake you can do is say okay i'm
going to tell this story and then i'm
going to get really emotional
so that the audience will know how
emotionally i was affected at that
time but you're still telling it in the
past tense
and when she looked at me i was when i
wanted to cry and then she did this and
then she did that
and you know what we have now therapy
why am i telling the story am i telling
the story because i want to go through
those emotions again
because we can feel the audience can
feel that emotion is not connected with
the story that
that emotion is connected with the
memory of the story
so the emotional journey of the
character does not belong
in that narrator it belongs
in the naive narrator now the naive
narrator just say
you know and she's looking at me and i'm
really scared now i'm in the present
tense and i go
that's totally acceptable because you're
telling me what's going on and how
you're feeling which is also what's
going on
in the moment but
if the naive narrator tries to put this
into some larger perspective
i'm looking at her you got to understand
you know i
i've really had a lot of trouble with
relationships for a long time
you go where are you going why are you
thinking about that in the middle of
this
this moment with this woman why
that's the job of the omniscient
narrator
they each have separate jobs and they
have to you have to be
purely in one or the other
all the time you also have an
interrogation process
for writers with the travis technique
right and it's entitled meet your
characters
that's part of it uh because you start
out saying interrogation process for
writers which
there are a lot of techniques within
that
and the interrogation process
just to be clear about what it is is
actually interrogating um
a character who lives inside an actor
or an individual so this interrogation
process which can
ignite characters inside the actors
we use this with writers and we show
writers how to do this
to actually meet their characters
either while after they've written the
screenplay while they're writing the
screenplay
often we've done it they even have an
idea for a screenplay
and they say we get a call say i'd like
to do meet your characters can you help
me
meet the characters that i have and so
the writer will then describe to us to
elsa and i
here here's the story here are the
characters we say fine
we'll gather together some actors who
are very skilled actors who we've worked
with before
and what we will do with these actors is
we will give
them um along with the
writer's understanding of what we're
doing a certain amount of information
about these characters sometimes it's
very little information
sometimes it's a lot of information all
depends on how developed the writer has
gone how far they've gone in the
development of the characters
and we will interrogate these actors
as these characters so we will turn
these actors into these characters
that's the interior and then we will put
actually put these characters together
we'll have them
interact we will have the show the
writer how
not only how to do the interrogation but
allow the writer
to actually engage with the characters
so let's say there's three or four
characters that we've interrogated and
they're all the characters now
all these actors have become the
characters and now the writer can engage
with the characters
and ask them questions
and interrogate them and start to learn
to he will actually
meet his characters sometimes the writer
says
will say to us i have this idea for a
scene i want between the husband and
wife
i say great great we'll do that during
the interrogation
we'll interrogate the husband and wife
and we'll put them into that scene
now there is no scene there's nothing
written
but it's a scene maybe when he comes
home and he discovers that she bought
the red dress that he told her she
couldn't buy or something like that
and he discovered that she bought it and
that's they have little very little
information
but enough information for a scene this
is important for a scene to get
started that's all there's no more
information beyond that there's no
information about what the father
the husband or the wife say or do and
there's no information about how the
scene
ends it's just enough to get them into
the scene because the important thing
about interrogation
is once we interrogate an actor as the
character that character
knows nothing about the script or the
story
nothing now the actor may know a lot but
the character knows nothing the
character
is totally naive so we can send those
characters into
a scene just enough to get the scene
started and see what happens and now the
writer is sitting there
watching an interaction between two of
his characters
happen something he hasn't even written
yet can we try that now with something
we can we can and keep in mind i'm not a
professional writer here so this is
going to be a very very
light story um so my character that i've
come with
up with is her name is jill she's 26
years old
she's unmarried and she has a seven
month old baby with a man named jack
so because of some life issues jill and
jack have lost their right to stay at
jill's grandmother's home
where they were all living and then
after being kicked out of there they
move into jack's brother's home
and jack's brother is kind of several
steps up he has a stable job and a
family life
but before you know it jill and jack are
then again asked to leave
and they have with their baby baby maya
and so now they've been
asked to leave two places um
so before jill fell into this situation
she um planned on going to chef school
and she was always artistic the
situation you mean pregnancy
uh and meeting jack i think jack
came before the pregnancy
that's true it wasn't an immaculate
conception yeah no no but
you said this situation before she got
into this relationship this relationship
right yeah and and then
this baby and then being bounced around
from these different
she wanted to go she wanted to be a chef
yeah she wanted to be a chef and she was
very artistic
and um unfortunately some of her demons
got the better of her
and she met jack while attending night
school
for this this chef sort of career and
they both fell into the world of
partying and it got the better of them
so now here they are they've been kicked
out of their second place with a seventh
month old baby
and uh i want to get to know jill better
okay and this uh karen is your creation
is
this this character is your creation
yeah just for the sake of this interview
yeah i'm not it's not like i'm writing
something no but it's your creation it
didn't come from something else
no no just jack and jill or you know
those are
those are used elsewhere but yeah so now
you want to meet that character
yeah the character okay that's fine so i
need to talk to jill
okay okay do you want me to be am i jill
or
this is where jill lives inside you
okay so i need to talk to jill okay okay
jill
yes i work how old are you i'm 26 26
and you wanted to be a chef i do you
still want to be a chef i do i love the
cooking channel
um i love making things yeah making food
into pastries or cakes or casseroles or
salad
what what kind of what kind of chef do
you want to be an assortment maybe less
with meat more
vegetarian more vegetarian vegan yeah
but you love cooking mm-hmm so do you
but but you're you're married now are
you oh you're not married
but you have a child correct okay and
but you're still pursuing being a chef
um i don't know how i'm gonna balance
i don't know i want him to watch her but
he
you want him to watch you want jack to
watch your
child but he won't i mean
he's not what is it what is he doing
he's not reliable what is he doing is he
working
not right now he was or he's not working
he was and are you working now
not right now and in order to pursue
being a chef what do you have to do
well i need to go back and finish these
other credits
there's a couple classes i didn't finish
oh you've got a couple classes you have
to finish and then you get a certificate
or a degree or something
right and then i want to be accepted
into this other like more professional
chef school
okay and then to move on to a more
professional school so you got a plan
this is this i mean this is a plan i
maya wasn't planned
i didn't say that it doesn't mean i
don't love it in terms of chefing
being a chef you have a plan right the
gut that sort of got interrupted a
little bit
a little bit but you know that happens
yeah so it happens to a lot of people
so when are you going to start you know
working on these credits
well i need like my grandmother was
paying for it
and then does jack love you
in his own way what does that mean
he has a weird his his own way of loving
what what is it
he has like trust issues trust trustee
we both do
it's not just him i have trust issues
can you trust him
not with money no not with money
i mean he you want to marry him
if he if he stops drinking i do if he
stops oh he's got a drinking problem
yeah
he's got a drinking problem he doesn't
have a job you can't trust him
why would he he's a good guy he's a good
guy for what
does he watch after mia does he want you
to go back to chef school
i think he gets jealous he wants you to
go back to chef school he's jealous i'm
going to meet someone there
oh no he's jealous you're going to meet
someone so he wants to keep you at home
because he saw my instructor and i were
working
and he just said like i don't like the
way you stare at him and he stares at
you
is that why he was so excited when you
got pregnant
don't know how excited he was
is that his way of keeping you at home
jill
why does he want to keep you at home
he's not doing anything
when you're at home with me where's jack
he's watching tv he's watching tv he
needs his time
to watch sports and drink and and just
be like is that what he says or is that
what you say
well i want to respect him and his
wishes do you respect him
and his wishes to stay home and watch tv
and drink
beer with his friends is that what he
does
no i mean i i mean yeah that's what he
does but i don't
why were you kicked out of the house
um we got some fights
with who uh well he got mad at my
grandmother and my grandmother said that
he took some money
from from her i don't think he did i
think it was somebody else
but she blames do you think he could
have
maybe do you think he was capable of
that
yeah but i i don't she doesn't like him
and so anything he does
like she just automatically wants to
blame them
yeah and who during that argument
between your grandmother and jack right
what did you say why did you defend
jill i guess you defend jack
i asked him to keep his voice that he
yells at her and i don't like
that keeping his voice down that's not
the issue the issue is she accused him
of stealing some money and she's going
to kick him out of the house
who were you defending
i was defending him why he's just had it
rough
and so he oh so you have to take care of
him
you have to protect him now you have two
children jill
you have two children one's only a few
months old
the other one's in his 20s or something
is this the way the rest of your life is
going to go
do you love your grandmother i know do
you love your grandmother
yes i do she's believed in me when
she's always good to you yes she took
you in when you needed help
when you got pregnant and you didn't
know where to go she
protected you and then you protected him
against her
if you left jack with mia
could you go back to live with your
grandmother
she says she won't give me any more
money i didn't ask you that
could you live with her
maybe would she watch mia she loves me
yeah she's been she's been willing to
watch her but she doesn't
like his drinking so she's no no i
didn't say him
he's not going back you're going back
with mia
would she let you live with her you and
mia
but then he'll just be gone i know he'll
be gone
would it's not an answer would she let
you live with her
would she watch mia for you would she
let you go back to school
would she support you the way jack
doesn't
[Music]
what do you want jill i just want us all
to be happy the three of us
well that's great everybody wants that
what are you going to do but i think
that with the right
time he can be better right time for
what
just if he just needs someone to believe
in him no one believed in him and so he
needs people to believe in him no one
believes in him so
i believe in him it's your job to
believe in him
and do you believe in him if he could
just
no do you believe in him
it's easy to say you believe in someone
if they stop all the horrible things
they're doing anybody can say that
do you believe in him now have he not
stopped anything he's still drinking he
still doesn't trust you
he's horrible with money he's not going
to support you he's not going to watch
the child for you to go back to school
he's not doing any of that
do you believe in him he's do you want
to be a place
what's that he's in a negative place
right now he certainly is do you believe
in him do you want to be with him jill
i believe in you do you want to be with
me i do want to be with him
why because we you know
things were better before like you know
his current behavior and he just had
more he was just fun and and
[Music]
i think that he just needs some time to
to become a better
person you know he didn't have a lot of
role models growing up and i know that's
i can't like use that as an excuse but
i just think that if someone believes in
him he will turn it around
if someone and that someone happens to
be you
but you don't believe in him
some days it's clear that you don't
believe in some days i do or some days
oh that's great
how about 100 believe in him 100 percent
love him 100 support him he changes when
he drinks
so he says he just wants to have a beer
every now and then and watch
if you could wave a magic wand
what would you ask for that
we would get married and that he would
stop drinking and that we would both get
jobs
and we wouldn't have to rely on my
grandmother
that you would get married yeah does he
want to get married
he says one day what's up one day i mean
his parents weren't married
so what so and it doesn't mean anything
so he doesn't believe in the institution
of marriage
i see so he really doesn't want to get
married
but you want to get married yeah does he
want to get a job
that was part of the magic wand thing is
that he got a job does he want to get a
job
have you ever heard him talk about a job
that he really wants
and that he's willing to go for it
what does he want to do besides sit home
and drink and watch tv
like i said he's just in a bad place
right now and then if you could just get
him in a better place then
jill you're living with a parasite you
know that
he's going to suck everything out of you
everything
all your energy all your joy all your
talent
all your hopes all your dreams
until you're sucked dry and then he'll
probably leave you
but i don't want mia to grow up without
a father
i want her to have him there i mean i i
know he's not perfect
i'm not perfect i'm not perfect so
i can't expect him to be perfect you can
expect him to be better than he is
you can expect him to respect you
you can expect him to love you you can
expect him to support you
you can expect him to sacrifice things
that are important to him
to help you if it's a marriage
just being married won't make it any
better you know that
it'll be just the same as it is now
well he says he loves mia
and i'm sure he does i'm sure he does
do you love mia absolutely do you want
her to grow up with a father like that
just because he's the biological father
he's the only choice
i just don't want to do that to her
do what do what i don't want her to not
know who raised her
i mean like who who her dad was i don't
want her she doesn't know it
she can know him like question mark she
can know him
how are you going to protect me
i know one day she'll be strong and
she'll see that he does love her
he's just going through some he just
he's not perfect he has
issues but i'm not perfect either so i
can't
totally just expect him to be perfect
you know
he says that i nag him all the time and
that i'm always on this case
okay so so you're so you're going to
um hang in there
yeah i thought about maybe moving back
to my grandmother's with me
and then but i don't know where he's
going to go so
but do it you can do that move back with
your grandmother
you're a beautiful strong vibrant young
woman who wants to be a chef
you have everything in front of you you
can make any choice you want to make
just make it there's nothing stopping
you
but what's going to happen to him he
doesn't have anywhere to go who knows
that's his problem
i just don't want him to become more
self-destructive than he already is
it may happen but it won't be your fault
he's a great father isn't he
like i said when he's in a good place
he's a good place he's a great father
he seems like it i mean and you're happy
when he's a great father
right when he's a good place yeah
so stay with him just stay with him
maybe it'll work out who knows
he just he doesn't like it when i like
not that i'm not telling him where i'm
going and he wants to like know like
where i am all the time and so
it's just hard for me to like have a
life and then he's there and i
you know if you could tell
jack anything you wanted without fear
of what would happen anything
what would you tell him i just want to
see him
be better and believe in himself and
just
he doesn't need to always have like a
beer
it seems like every hour with that's
what you want to tell him
i just i want to see him like be the
person i know he can be
what do you really think of him i think
that he
just never had anyone believe in him but
i see a difference what do you think of
him what do you jill
think of jack
i don't know he's become so negative i'm
gonna ask you one last question
if you had to do headed to do all over
again
would you have gotten involved with jack
no
no i would have stayed at the school and
just
okay kept going okay
now we're gonna stop okay
so what was that like painful
painful yeah i feel bad for jill okay
she's stuck you know and um
you know she doesn't have any resources
and she's relying on his grandmother
and um
[Music]
you know maybe jack's a good guy but
she's not that's not her
fault it's not she can't fix him but um
she's like stuck in this pit and you're
right she's taking care of two children
and um i guess i want her to have a
backbone
you want her to have a backbone yeah but
the since
since we did this because of meet your
characters right
and this is not about you karen playing
jill this is about you meeting the jill
that's
existing inside you sure
um were there any surprises
how much maybe she made excuses for all
these things or
like you brought them out to light and
she just kept like making excuses for
them
like if only if only if only sure in a
perfect world but
a perfect world and if it just needs
time i mean all the all the excuses that
she makes
for him which i don't think she would
make
if it wasn't for mia um that's
interesting
yeah that's true because the child
changed everything not getting together
with jack it was the child
right changed everything and it changed
her perspective
that's true and protecting him
protecting him because you're really
protecting her and the whole thing
you want her to have a father i said
well you know she can have a father
there's more than one out there
that's true that could be the father but
that's you know
because lots of times when we do this um
this process
with the writer treating you as the
writer of this story
is that the writer will discover things
about
their protagonist or any character in
their story that they
never imagined just because it's done
through the interrogation
process where the character is actually
speaking now
it's coming from within the writer but
it's because of the way the process
works
of the very intense probing questions
that's why it's called interrogation
probing questions about who you are
and there's something unique that i've
been experiencing for years now for both
writers and actors when they go through
this process
because they're under the pressure of
the character having to answer
immediately not under the pressure of oh
let me think about that i'll
journal about that let me think about
let me think about what jill would do in
that circumstance
that that can't play at all what plays
is jill is being asked
and you're playing and you are being
jill and jill has to answer
and so jill i'm sure you experienced
that like i have
yeah i karen can't stay oh excuse me i
don't know the answer to that can we go
on to
no there's no there's no room for that
jill
has to answer and so many times you're
surprised by what
the what comes out of the character or
the character's perspective or point of
view or something
and we've done this many times where
writers have said
my god i didn't know he or she thought
that
it's amazing no it's not because of
something i do in other words i'm not
injecting
information into the character at all
i'm just questioning
the character and the character has to
answer and you're in
and you're free to say anything you want
and the answer you want
so that a lot of times they're surprised
but the character does exist inside you
because you created that character and
you know that character better than
anybody
and all we're doing is moving
you the writer out of the way
so you i'm i'm not allowing you karen
the writer to control the character
you just have to sit on the side and
watch the character emerge
and be questioned and be interrogated
and be herself
then you go wow that's a different
person than i thought
i was scared you're interrogating
because i i saw that my life was like
backed into this corner and that there
were no solutions
to it and
[Music]
you know it's loose i had thought of a
story like this
years ago i never really did much with
it but it was kind of based on
people that i would see um that were
like young families that kind of like
lived in
trailers and different things and i
always wondered like how did they get
there i'm sure that's not something they
planned and
um you know how do we know
that couldn't have been any of us right
there with the with the
certain set of circumstances and so you
know you'll just see someone on the
street and you just like
start wondering about their life and um
just just yeah i felt like
i think i felt more like jill than i
ever had i actually had a different
name for the character before but um we
changed it because it was so it was a
different name it was like very unusual
but i did i felt very scared and like i
had no choices and no
no say no agency in my own life and so
you were
showing me as jill that like you know
there's not many places to go with this
you know
so yeah and a lot of what we do with
jill too
is and this happens a lot of
interrogation is push the character
up against their obstacles and it's um
the obstacles that are inside them the
fears i mean
jill's fear of not having
jack around which is really irrational
but
understandable understandable because
that's what happens
but like how because even when i said
move back with the grandmother and all
that you and mia but
you say yeah but what's going to happen
to jack i go
excuse me i'm giving you an opportunity
to get out of a bad situation and all
you want to do is get back in it
but just to run into that so we you know
it's it's a matter of pushing the
character
up against even their fears or their
denial or their rationalization or
justification
and question it not saying it's wrong
but just can you
explain to me why you think that way
that's all i was doing
explain that to me and i could see you
you're going oh yeah
i can't i can't well then we have a
problem
that's it great that's what
and that's what we do with and now
there's one other thing
that process is similar to what we do
with writers with the write your life
too
except we're interrogating them as
themselves at a different time
but it's the same process and the same
many times the same thing will happen
even you go oh wow i didn't know that
that's what i was thinking back then
and what happens when it's with write
your life or autobiographical
is and i'm very much aware of this and i
have to be a little more delicate
sometimes
because i'm actually interrogating you
as you so i have to be much more careful
i can't
be as aggressive sometimes
because but many times what i'm
triggering
is the truth that has been buried
and the people are surprised that this
came out and they they can feel that
it's true they can feel that this is
what was really going on they could feel
that this was really the fears that they
were dealing with
and now they go back to look at the
story and they see it in a whole
different way because they see
their protagonist in a different way
yeah and i see this character in a
different way now
good we just finished the meet your
character
interrogation process mark where
hypothetical character i came up with
i'm wondering when you do this with
other writers
what's the most common reaction
afterwards that they have
after meeting their character okay um
if it's meeting the characters like we
did with you where the character comes
from within you
as opposed to meeting the characters
when they come out of actors
right i'm going back to what we did with
you
the reaction is
usually surprised by what they learned
that they didn't
know they're surprised by what the
character
says or what the character does or what
the character believes in or doesn't
believe in
and a lot of that of course i have no
idea what's going to come up because i
don't know
the characters that well as well as the
writer does
and i don't know how they perceive the
character and many times the writer will
perceive the character in a very
precious way
this is who she is and this is what i
want her to be
which is a very controlling way so then
what will happen during the
interrogation
is something to come out that is outside
of that or or different from that
perception that they have or that
creation that they have in their mind
that the character will start talking in
a way or behaving in a way or responding
in a way that they
that they never would have allowed the
character to do as the writer
but there's the character doing it
there's the character saying that
there's a character
expressing those feelings those ideas
and they're surprised so normally then
it would be
a group of actors or an actor as this
character jill or jack
these two characters or maybe even the
grandmother who knows
yeah and the writer would be watching
you interrogate those people
as those characters well yes i mean when
when we get into the write your life
with a writer and we have a group of
actors
who are going to become their characters
um it's it's a
a little more complicated process
because simult depending on who the
writer is simultaneously i have to
besides interrogating all the actors to
become those characters i have
i'm simultaneously training the writer
how to do this
how to to the very sort of the very
beginning steps of interrogation process
and how it can work
and then even then once i've
interrogated the actors to be those
characters i will bring the writer in to
start talking to the characters it won't
be just
me and to even get involved in the
interrogation
so that's the part of the meeting i can
be interrogating i can be interrogated
and an actor says jill the character we
just
did and i could have the writer right
next to me i could have you right next
to me if we're doing this and you're the
writer
and i could just tap you like go talk to
her
and keep keep up the interrogation just
keep it going and explore
and you may have other questions you
want to ask and and other other things
points of view you want to express to
her to see what's happening so there's
it's a process of not only just working
with the actors but bringing the writer
into the process and then eventually
engaging them with
all the characters and something that
elsia mentioned
um that just for the sake of the camera
i guess we couldn't do is that
i'm sitting in karen's seat
referring to myself in the third person
yeah so the lines between jill and karen
are going to be sort of they'd be if i
was standing up
and outside of this seat then it would
be more that i'm jill i guess
yeah you feel you feel more of a
separation right
exactly interesting great
do you find that writers become quite
emotional
because they've met their characters um
sometimes yeah sometimes they um
sometimes emotional because they are
responding to the characters
i guess in a way that they hope that the
audience will that they're actually
meeting them and realizing how
vulnerable they are or how scared they
are or how magnificent they are and
going wow this
is really um moved
by the characters and sometimes they'll
become very emotional when
something will happen between two of the
characters
[Music]
that they hadn't imagined but actually
is
um working into the story that they want
to tell
let's say it's just between two
characters who have never met before
and suddenly there's a connection and
one character says he feels that way
about the other characters they'll
talk about how they feel in the
interrogation how they feel about each
other and how they see each other
and sometimes the writer will oh my god
i never imagined that that could happen
there could be that connection between
the two and they'll become emotional
because of that because it's a richness
of the characters and the character
relationship that they hadn't really
conceived of yet and then do you find
conversely that they don't like their
character they don't have any empathy
toward them
and they go you know what i need to go
back to the drawing board this isn't the
character
that i thought they were yeah and
yeah sometimes they're going oh okay
that character didn't turn out the way i
had hoped then it would be going back to
okay what were you looking for
because we're basing it on what you told
me or you told us
and maybe you need to alter something
along those lines and we could do it
again
quite honestly we could do it again
almost immediately if they say i want to
i want to approach this character in a
different way
say okay let's do it talk about it and
the actor can be sitting there listening
to it
and say okay we're going to approach the
character or i'll go to another actor so
i'm going to do another actor for that
character
and start interrogating them and
interrogate them into the character
again
and we'll have a different version of
the character
man i would love to that i mean that
just sounds
so exciting even though i'm not really
invested in this character that i have
this hypothetical
story but um just it sounds like really
really fascinating to see
this thing that was in your imagination
just like
very powerful good you talk about
something called the bully and the
butterfly
your committee as it relates to meeting
characters
yes another big topic and i
think karen i think we talked about this
in the last interview
many many years ago okay my memories no
no no no that's
no that's okay this this has to do with
the committee
now the committee i'll explain
in fact in the interrogation that we
just did
there was the committee but i'll explain
how that works
the um the term committee
the way we use it stan
represents all the voices in your head
so all the voices in your head karen or
david head
david's head houses there's many voices
in there
and as you know these voices in our
heads that we all have
we talk to them they talk to us they
criticize us they praise us
they advise us or whatever they get in
the way sometimes
and there are a lot of them that's why i
call it the committee
because i feel like there's a lot in my
head i feel like there's a lot of these
voices and they are
sometimes in session discussing
something
so the voices in the head of us as
humans are very important because i feel
like
my committee your committee david's or
else's committee
or i'll go back to your committee for
karen your committee
knows everything about you everything
even stuff that nobody else knows it's
in there
somewhere so when you think about the
fact that we have all these voices in
our head and these voices know
everything about us and
each voice in our head has different
opinions about that subject or that
topic or any subject or any topic
this is a very rich territory inside any
human being
but then think about a character a
character in a movie
a character like jill jill has a
committee
and if you could get into her committee
if you could
visit her committee you would know more
about
jill but the problem is in screenplays
and most stories that were plays however
they were written
we are given no information at all about
the committee inside a character
nothing we know what the character does
we know what the character says we know
what the character
expels she expresses herself what she
wants what her needs are
we get a little idea of what she's
afraid of and all that but we really
don't know what's going on
inside her head okay
because inside her head inside jill's
head
are all of these voices
right now what is it the butt butterfly
and the
and the bully the bully the bully and
the butterfly
yeah colin you're committing yeah the
bully now what i just did
with you with jill and that was mostly
the bully the bully that there's a voice
inside jill's head which is saying
get out get out get out get out get out
what you ex kept trying to hold on to
was another voice this will work this
will work
if i give him time you're trying that's
the butterfly
if you're trying to hold on sometimes
there were a couple of times when i was
talking to you i would support the
butterfly
but then i would go back to the bully so
the thing is there's a war
going on inside the committee
there's a war going on inside every one
of our committees it's ju
it's it's chaos in there so the
interrogation
is giving voice to all of those voices
so every time i i can attack you about
something
i can praise you about something those
are two different voices of the
committee
inside jill's head and jill
by jill you as voicing jill
responding to those voices of her
committee
every time you respond jill gets formed
a little bit more
a little bit more a little bit more so
jill is getting
formed by forming the committee
not by telling the actress or the writer
who
jill is but by forming jill
through the interrogation process
and then are they also forming who jack
is
same thing because they're confronting
her on these different things
well i mean by confronting well we're
forming
yes we're forming jill's point of view
of jack now if i interrogate jack
or if i interrogate you as jack or
interrogate somebody else as jack
it won't be the same as jill jack has
his point of view
jack has his jack has his committee
his committees that says you know she
should take care of me this is what the
you know she's the wife i'm just making
it up i don't know
but he will have his committee that
justifies his behavior
or questions his behavior he's got
a different committee but it's also in
chaos so these committees are in chaos
and it's building a character from deep
deep inside the character
where quite respectfully to writers and
actors
writers and actors will create the
character from
outside writers will design a character
you design this character
actors will look at a script and go okay
oh no i
i can design a character that will do
those things that are in the script
but that's not really developing the
character at all that's really
creating sort of like a puppet that will
do the things that are demanded in the
script
the thing is what's going on inside that
character
that causes him or her to do those
things in the script
that's what you have to build and that
has to be built
from way deep inside not on the outside
so when someone's writing a script and
we're not connecting to the character
is that because it's almost a puppet it
could be
it could be a two-dimensional character
yep a puppet who's just
doing i mean we've all seen films or
plays or whatever
where our television where we go
the only reason that characters doing
that is because the writer needs them to
do that
right so it's not the character it's the
writer
pulling strings to get the character to
do that so that the story will work out
that happens too often
and why do you think this this meeting
their characters and the interrogation
why do you think it just
puts you in a different mindset because
i'm already in a different mindset about
a character that
i just kind of like came up with and
i've been thinking about for years but
never really did anything with
so i'm not totally invested but now like
i feel like that person is real
from just sitting here with you for that
10 to 15 minute span
why do you think it works what is it
that happens
i think part of the reason it's a great
question i think
part of the reason it works
for both writers and actors but we'll
talk about writers for a second
is because that's sort of the situation
you're in with jill
is suddenly there's a respect for
another human being
you feel like there's another human
being existing who's jill
and i've met her or there's these other
human beings of these characters that i
thought i created
i've met them in person and i
now i have an obligation to them
as the writer to honor them
not i have a task of creating them
i have a task of honoring them and who
they are and what that relationship is
so i think there's a there's a um a
different respect
and i think the same thing happens for
actors when they've been interrogated
they
feel they've had this experience of this
character that lives inside them and
still it's like i need to honor this
this person
there is there is another person it's
not just
me acting so acting sort of goes away
yeah i don't know if you saw joker but
yeah if you saw
the way joaquin phoenix approached the
character of arthur fleck i mean
whether you want to say it was a
terrible human being
but you there were just so many moments
where you had at least for me as a
viewer
i had so much empathy yeah for that
character and i think that's through
joaquin's
you know treating him it's just he was a
real yeah it's his total immersion
yeah i mean it's an extraordinary
performance absolutely
and his total immersion into
that tortured human being
and it's interesting because he ends up
becoming he ends up doing
horrible things evil things killing
people
and yet i have empathy for him because
he's so tortured he's so
you know it's i mean that's an
extraordinary achievement
absolutely and the same with renee
zellweger as uh judy yeah
garland yep same thing you know
especially from just the opening scene
just
showing up the hotel with the kids and
then
not knowing if she could stay or not and
just yeah this like fragility
but then this like you know on stage
persona
it was just seeing characters like that
like you just
all time goes away yeah you know and in
that moment when you were asking
about my character time went away and i
felt like i was hurt
good we talked about compression and
expansion of time when it comes to a
writer meeting their character
okay um that that's that's really not
with the writers meeting the characters
oh okay but that's okay but
compression and expansion it has a lot
to do with
the write your life autobiographical
storytelling
the thing is that we
have a tendency by instinct or whatever
to
not only tell things in a chronological
order but to tell them
pretty much in real time and we will
tell this happened then this happened
then this happened
in other words time will feel as we're
telling the story that time is moving at
its normal pace
compression and expansion are two
techniques of playing with time
and storytelling one is compressing time
and the other is expanding it
compressing time is i could move you
through i could be telling you a story
and i can move you through
a part of the story much faster
much faster than
real time very very very very fast
and what a couple things that happens
and i'll try to give you an example
i'm going back to my driving on the 405
which is a story i just
made up um see if i can do it with that
and let's say that that's the story of
me having a tough day and i'm
racing i'm on the 405 racing to get to
an appointment or something like that
that's when i see the yellow car
but i want to tell you what the rest
let's say i want to tell you what
the rest rest of the day has been like
up till that point
but it's been a long day and there's
been a lot of things that have happened
so many that if i start listing them all
you go fine fine
fine fine and emotionally it won't do
much of it you're just gonna you'll just
get a lot of information
like if i told you that my alarm clock
didn't go off when i wanted to so i got
up late
and then i had problems with the shower
because i promised myself i'd fix it and
it was it wasn't fixed and i had to hold
it with one hand
and then as i was getting dressed i
spilled something on my favorite shirt
and then i went on and on and on
and then i did this and then as i was
going to get to the appointment i'm
going outside and my neighbor
who was really annoying wanted to talk
and she won't start talking
and then like i talked to her for a
while and then i'm going on then trying
to get to the car
now the car is fine except i should have
washed it i should have realized that
i'm going to meet this person he's going
to see my car and the car is dirty
now i could tell you know say all these
things are going on but i say i don't
want to
even take as much time as i just took
to tell that and also after a while it
goes yeah got it
yes got it got it it's been a bad day
got it got it got it
if i compress it i can tell it
very much faster much faster and
still take you on an emotional journey
let me say i'm up up up in the morning
alarm clock didn't work didn't work
didn't work supposed to be 6 30. got to
get there on time take a shower
shower's broken always been broken my
fault should have fixed it got to get
there on time where's that shirt there's
the shirt beautiful shirt put on the
shirt spill the
spill the oatmeal on it oh damn oatmeal
change the shirt don't like the shirt
gotta go gotta go outside there's rhonda
she wants to talk
can't talk hot gotta go gotta go get in
the car get in bye rhonda does she's
still talking about i wanna get in the
car should've washed the car why didn't
i wash the car
this is an important thing i should have
washed the car he's gonna see the car
got to get going
now that i just covered the same amount
of time
same amount of events but faster
and it becomes more poetic and becomes
more fractured
time that's compressing time now we do
the this
is built on what we can do in film
with jump cutting and fast cutting and
we've all seen that when it goes
we start moving moving through time
faster and it puts us in a different
rhythm and it puts us in a different
energy and it creates an
urgency just by the construction of it
of those fast cuts just by the
construction of jumping jumping jumping
jumping through all with all of that
and actually in the piece that i just
did
i wove through one phrase
that i kept repeating which you may not
recall it doesn't matter
the rep the phrase was gotta get there
on time
gotta get there on time and i can weave
that through and you may or may not
notice it you may not be
that's sort of like a little mantra that
keeps repeating
which is really what the whole
compression is about
so that's compression so many times when
we're doing these large stories
and someone says well you have to
understand everything that was happening
up until then say i got it but
we'll have to compress it it takes a lot
of work to do that
it takes a lot of work to explore that
amount of time what really happened and
then to write it
and then compress it the other one
which is much more powerful is the
expansion of time
the expansion of time we use when you
hit a point in the story
you're telling a story and it's usually
the point the key
moment in the story it's the key moment
if it's a love story it's a key moment
of the first kiss or maybe if it's a
frightening traumatic story
it's when you witness something that
just
changed your life something maybe
horrible
or maybe it was a car accident or
something or
something happened in the story which
just riveted you
and it's one of those moments when you
know something happens and your whole
body seems to change
what ripples through you the
embarrassment the
fear the shame the horror the disgust
the joy whatever is going it's just
rippling through you then you say okay
how do i tell that
and you don't want to go along and say
then i you know i looked at her looked
in her eyes
and then and then i'm kissing her and it
really felt great and
because that's all and i'm moving on you
go that's it
the expansion of time is what we do is
we stop time
we literally stop the story
so if it is the kiss and if it's you're
talking about that moment of that first
kiss
and you say i'm looking at her eyes and
her eyes are looking up at me
and i can see the sparkle in her eyes
and i
i can feel that yes this is the moment i
reach in and i start to kiss her and
my lips touch her lips and lips
touching lips warm soft
smooth joy oh
tears my tears her tears
oh touching touching wanting
needing needing feeling
breathe breathe
breathe and then i can pull myself out
of it
now that's an expansion an expansion of
time stops
the story and what it does is it
we keep telling the story but we drop
down
inside the character to really explore
what's going on
in that moment of time and time is not
moving
forward at all or if it is it's just
inching forward maybe a little
bit it's almost like slow motion now in
cinema we use slow motion and things
like to get that same feeling
here we do it because we're not getting
dealing with anything visual
we're doing it just with words just with
words
and the main things that expansion needs
it needs a trigger something to
send you into that this moment the
trigger was the lips touching
something that visually or essentially
that
send you in and it needs a release
something
to bring you out something to snap you
out of it
so that you can go back into real time
so that's that's
expansion the the release i didn't put
in
yet because i wanted to explain it first
because you have to plan the release and
if so if i'm in the middle of that kiss
and i'm talking about soft touching
kitchen now my planned release
i'm not going to bring myself out of
that feeling because it's such a
delicious feeling
even if it's a horrible traumatic
feeling you may want to bring yourself
out but you can't
something else has to bring you out of
it somebody saying my name
would bring me out of it so if it's
touching the
lips touch warm smooth touching lips
more
want more and more mark yeah something
like that
pam so then it brings me out of it so
that's what expansion expansion allows
you to just
immerse yourself in the the joy or the
horror
or the trauma or the exhilarates
whatever it is
of the moment of that key moment and
usually this is
what the whole story is aiming for at
this moment anyway and you want to take
time with it
that's expansion do you think that
people should follow
their dreams and along those lines if
they
should follow their dreams when should
an artist leave their day job
boy that's that's a tricky one it's a
really tricky question because there's a
part of me i'll give you
this is my committee giving several
answers
okay there's a part of me that says
don't leave your don't leave your day
job
until it becomes absolutely impossible
to stay in it
because of the dream you're following
see how long you can stay
in the day job
and i'm just thinking about security and
all that then there's another part
that says i'll leave it just go at any
time
now i'm in some in some ways i'm not a
great person to ask this because
um when i started in this business i've
had very few quote
day jobs i've been i've just been able
to create a lot of jobs or create a lot
of work or do a lot of things that i
wanted to do and then
there were times years and years and
years ago 30 40 years ago i had day jobs
while i was still pursuing this but as
soon as i got a job
directing or job something in the
business day job was gone
immediately so i was one of those that
would just quit immediately
but then sometimes months later i would
find myself in deep trouble
because that job was over the job i did
it was fine
that done but there was no job following
it
and then i was found myself scrambling
again
to put something together at least to
support myself so i don't you know but
the following of the dreams
i think the the big question
is do you have a plan do you have a
vision of how you're going to
uh pursue uh what you want
and this is also from personal
experience
i've at times
unfortunately relied too heavily on
jobs showing up or someone helping me
out
and not taking care of it myself
then i've swung the other way and
created a whole business on my own to
support myself
which is and still in my business which
i'm doing now to support myself so i've
gone both
both ways i think it's looking at
what is what is my plan what is my plan
for today or let's put it this way
this has something to do with what else
and i are looking into now
is what your dream
where do you imagine you would be five
years from now following your dream
can you imagine where you would be and
what and just
write about what that is and describe
what that is
okay now come back where would you be
five months from now in that dream
describe that
okay then you come back where would you
be
five days from now following your dream
and can you describe that now you
described goals and pinpoints
and then the last thing is what can you
do in the next hour
to fulfill that dream doing that you'll
start to
see possibly a plan a goal
a map of some sort i think too many
people
are following dreams i want to be a
great actress i want to be a great
writer but there's no map
there's no i'm going to i'm going to
write a screenplay
three screenplays this year three
different genres that's a plan
can you do that while you have your day
job sure you can so i think it's a
matter of really
being realistic about not just what the
dream is
but what how you envision you might get
there
chances are it won't work exactly that
way but chances are if you have that
vision
you're going to come somewhat close or
at least be moving in that direction
are you almost relieved that
you didn't take a day job
you know you said you would work at one
directing thing or something
then as many industry jobs
another one um but if you
had had something more cush or that it
was just more stable
then you wouldn't have created what
you've created more push or stable like
what
well if if you just had like this steady
job after job you said sometimes you
you waited and you relied too much on a
job being there for you
and and maybe it wasn't at times maybe
that was a painful lesson
um do you think that in some ways that
was a good painful lesson because then
it
ignited in you to start you know what
you started and
write and do these classes and and the
travis institute and all these different
things
yeah it's i mean it did the everything
i'm doing now that elsa and i are doing
now together which started many many
years ago
was generated was started out of that
desperation
out of that desperation i have to do
something
and because of who i am or whatever my
personality what i did not pursue
was a typical day job
whether it's waiting on tables or
working for a
company or something like that my
fallback has always been create
something
so i would create a job and that was
creating workshops that i was teaching
first for actors and then for directors
i would keep creating something that
didn't exist
that i could do which would keep me
close to what i was doing anyway i
didn't want to go and work
in you know nine to five in some you
know office building i just
that would be just too devastating to me
too demoralizing for me
so that's what i would do but i would
wait a long time
before doing that until it was desperate
and then i would have to
put something together rather quickly to
keep everything going then ironically
with the teaching
that i was doing it became
more than just a day job it became an
entire business
became an entire business that you know
resulted in what i'm doing now which is
traveling around the world
and teaching and many times i go what
what happened to my other job
the directing thing all the other stuff
i was doing because this has become
um so you know
massive of what i'm doing and now with
elsa what
else and i are doing together that
it has taken over and sometimes i i
think what would happen
what would happen now if i was offered a
directing thing
like well we'd have to make some big
shifts and changes
so but that and that's okay but that
that's the way my life has always been
it's always been
um a bit chaotic
and under my control which means
sometimes out of control
but at the end of the day you're still
working with story
still doing this that's something you
love yeah yeah i
if well if you're going to create
something you might as well create
something you enjoy doing so i wouldn't
create something i enjoy doing
or that i knew i was good at and that i
could
survive at if i could just construct
something
[Music]
um along the lines so the teaching and
the coaching
and the consulting and all of that falls
right in that although it's not
directing but
you know it's all around it is and all
my
directing skills and my writing skills
you know
um supply that support that
that process so i'm not that far away
from what i was doing in fact i've moved
way beyond what i was
doing so again going back to when should
an artist create uh
when should an artist quit their day job
it's when it becomes unbearable
at that day john unbearable
or their other thing becomes undeniable
in terms of supporting them
unbearable undeniable
yeah um yeah it's it's sort of in that
zone the reason i'm hesitating is
because i just remembered something
um that happened to me they were again
doing a lot of the teaching stuff there
was a time this was back in the early
90s
and i was teaching a lot of workshops
and
um doing
you know doing what i was doing teaching
workshops and and trying to get
directing jobs and
through a series of circumstances which
are not
important right at the moment i got a
job
directing a feature film for warner
brothers okay
and there was a long story on how that
all happened that's not important
and i the important part is okay now i'm
directing this
film it's a low budget film but it's for
a major studio and i'm getting all the
studio support and everything's going
fine
and i'm still doing in my other i'm
still running workshops i'm doing
everything else i was and i'm used to
doing 12 things at the same time
anyway and that's what my life was like
and i would have clients i would work
with
and i remember one meeting and we're
going into pre-production where the
producers from warner brothers
sat me down and said ah mark
you have to stop doing these other
things
i go why you know one workshop was on
wednesday evening
i'll be free on wednesday evenings the
other ones i could do on weekends i'm
free on weekends
no no no mark you have to you're
directing this
film yeah you had that has to be your
sole focus
and i remember resenting that going why
i don't want to do that
i want to do these other things too and
ironically
i did shut down all the other things but
the irony is
now we're deep into pre-production and
i'm we're working monday through friday
and i have a stu
at the studio and i have my office and
we're setting everything up
and i remember hitting the first weekend
and everybody said okay it's friday okay
see you on monday i go
monday well what are we doing saturday
and sunday
nothing well what am i gonna do saturday
i was so used to working seven days a
week
doing something every single day now i'd
shut down all the other stuff
and now i didn't have that other thing
so i had to make a whole
shift in my way of approaching the work
i mean it was absolutely right
you know i needed to totally focus on
the film
and i and i did and all that but that
was a shift so i think for anybody
considering
making that kind of change think about
what you're used to and what your
patterns are and what you can handle and
what you can't
handle and what the day job is and my
feeling is if you get to the point you
say i better quit the day job because
this other stuff that i'm doing
which is my dream is
demanding so much of my time and
attention and i say well
then it's time to quit it's time to quit
what did you end up doing for the first
few saturdays and sundays
of that directing job it was it was hard
it was it was really hard because there
was nobody in the office
nobody i could talk to you know i'd go
back and i'd read the script again and
i'd make
notes and i would do do my own research
or planning
but i'm the type of artist who loves to
collaborate i love other people being
around
so i love being at the studio i love
working with the designers i love
working with the casting director i
loved working with all these people and
suddenly you leave me for two days and
nobody to talk to
and i felt lost
and i was like we could be home with my
family that's fine but
i wanted to do i wanted to i really
literally i think at that time wanted to
why can't we work through the weekend
too
why do we have to stop for the weekend
but that's just my personality
it's a great story yeah
oh i like that
so then when that job was over you knew
was that was that your
your test well when when ironically when
that job was over
and now i had a terrific agency not an
agent but an agency working for me and i
was reading a lot of scripts because i
was directing of
a studio picture and um
scripts were being sent to me to see if
i was interested in it
and all of this the other thing and
i was trying the the goal now is to set
up the next project
because this project is coming near an
end set up the next project
and i r without i can't mention the
agencies and all that right
um my agent big agency
said you know i said let's set up the
next project and they said to me
the agency said to me uh well let's see
how this movie does first
and i'll never forget this and i was
sitting there
and there were inquiries from other
studios about
things and i said well can we set
something let's see how this film does
first and i knew at that moment
because we're near we're near the end of
post-production
that the film was not going to do well
for a lot of reasons
i knew that it's not it's not going to
be like wow let's hire this guy
even though the reactions to the footage
and the reactions to the performances
all were great and everything i
said this is not going to do well and i
knew why
and i said to the agent i said listen
if the film does really well i don't
need you
if it doesn't do well you can't help me
i said we have to do it now and they
said no and i knew that that was the end
of my relationship with that agency and
it was i switched agents
but the film did not do well i did not
get another
job set up and i was doing fine because
the film paid well
but then that's only going to last so
long and it was months later
still trying to set up the next job that
i realized
i have to do something to generate
income
i can't go back and do theater now
because it'll take me too long to set up
a play that i'm going to direct
at a local theater i can't go back to
television because i've been out of
television for too long and it's going
to take time
i need in other words i need income now
and so i started teaching and that's
when
that was the beginning of the whole
teaching thing that has led to where i
am now
and then in between you've written two
books
written two books and there's another
one in the works
which will be done someday yep
that's a great story i'm sure it's a
painful one at that time yeah
oh yeah that's a great story it's very
painful to be
um i'll tell you one thing it's very
painful at that studio
which is a big studio and we were
shooting
on a lot that was not at that studio so
the times i would go to that studio
and people would see me while we were
shooting come on i love you phil love
your deal
i go to your dailies every day and this
is these are people who
are not working on the film they're just
at the studio they would just go to see
the stuff that we
shot so you have all that
that um
that build up that sort of support and
feeling like wow i'm
i'm doing well i'm doing well here all
of that and then during post-production
which is i could tell you this whole
story of post-production and how it all
slowly fell apart um
sometimes because of distrust sometimes
because of sabotage by other people
and sometimes because of infighting
inside the studio because there were
studio executives who wanted the film to
fail
and i ran into it and at the very end
of that whole journey with that studio
i was asked to meet with the head of the
studio
he was a sweet guy nice guy we had a
long talk about
and he said mark you were just in the
wrong place
at the wrong time
i go well that doesn't help me at all
so it was very it was very painful when
you think okay
now the career is starting to move now
i'm moving and now i'm doing well and
now they like the work
they like me and all that but
what is the truth behind the lie the
truth behind the lie
okay in um autobiographical storytelling
one thing we're very strict about to a
point
is we are telling the true story we're
sticking to the truth we're sticking to
the truth of characters
sticking to the truth of events we're
not
making up stuff and
but there are times when
we actually fictionalize the truth
fictionalize the truth in other words
lie to get closer to a deeper truth
in other words um
i'll give you an example when i was
developing um a bronx
tale and a bronx tale is about
yonkologio
and his father and the gangster
uh sonny and i said
to chaz i need a story
about your father you know and we need
some kind of story or event with your
father
that actually shows how he is
dealing with the conflict between
you that you have with this gangster
and how he's dealing with the gangster
and he says well there isn't any story
there isn't any story like that there
isn't any event
he said you know when they got together
or there
where he confronted the boy about it i
said well then we have to create one
and what we did is we created a story
so we could get closer to the truth of
how the father
felt about this chaz knew how he felt
about it but by creating a story
that really didn't happen any scene that
didn't happen
and in the film and in the play there
these scenes are still there
these scenes are still there that didn't
actually happen because they're
there to serve a purpose and the purpose
of these these
fictional scenes are these fictional
exchanges and sometimes
it even comes down to we will put words
in a character's mouth that they never
said
but those words reveal the truth of the
character we will
that's when we will fictionalize to get
closer to a truth
and that's allowed how do writers feel
about that
about the way well you talk about the
autobiographical part now sure
first of all the writer is the character
who lived through
this uh usually they feel fine about it
because many times i'll say okay in this
situation if your
father said this um let's say it's
the little boy this is not from the
bronx deal little boy the father and the
mother
and let's say there's an argument going
on between the little boy
and the father i said okay what what
happens if
if the mother was in that scene or heard
that scene what would she have said
oh it would have been awful really what
would she have said
and he would tell me that she would said
something like that um
give me an idea what she would said she
would have been horrified and furious
say fine let's put her in the scene
but she wasn't in the scene i know she
wasn't in the scene
but we're trying to get closer to what
the dynamics are in this relationship
and if we put her in the scene some so
many times we'll try we'll experiment
we'll rehearse
put her in the scene and have her say
that many times the writer getting back
to your question will go
that's no that's good that's good that's
what would have happened that's who they
are
and if i can if i can get to that point
where the writers say that's
really who they are that's the truth of
who they are
then i feel fine and they feel fine they
feel good because they've been
they've honored the truth of the
characters maybe not the truth of the
events
what is the gap the gap the gap
the gap not the store and not like
not a gas store but i like the t-shirt i
like the not only the tea i used to have
a t-shirt
but i like in london you know at the
tube mind
the gap oh when i when i started to
realize something very important this is
a long time ago when i was doing these
autobiographical pieces and i was
working on
one or two of them i forget which one
doesn't matter
when i realized that i knew what the
events were i knew what happened
they told me this is what happened what
happened and what happened
but then i realized that something was
missing in the telling of the story
and what was missing
was from the protagonist the main
character
the autobiographical character i wasn't
hearing what
they really wanted to have happen were
hoping would happen
and expecting to happen
in other words if it's if it's a
confrontation
let's make it very simple it's a guy
telling the story
and it's a story about him asking
um a beautiful young woman
to go to the prom with him and he tells
me what happens and what she said
and i realized what is missing in that
story is what he
thought was going to happen what he
hoped would happen what he
fantasized would happen now in other
words his pursuit is to ask
her to the prom and want and he wants
her to say yes
okay prior to
telling the whole story he need we need
to know what he thinks is going to
happen
how he's going to pursue that so that we
are riding with that character inside
his belief
inside his expectation inside his desire
so we are writing with him if we
if he leaves that out he just says i'm
going to ask her out and we don't know
how important this is we don't know
what's riding on it
we don't know what he's expecting if she
says yes we don't know what he's
expecting if he says no if we don't know
that
half of the scene is gone half of the
energy is gone
so what will happen what i realized when
i
started exploring this is this is the
way we all
go through life we all go
through life no different than this
interview all of us in this room the
four of us in this room
had an expectation of how this interview
would turn out
and i can tell you right now we are all
wrong
it has turned out differently
that's all just different it's
just different so if we
look at life as we move through life we
move through life we have a pursuit this
is what we're going to do
we talk about going to lunch i'm going
to have this meal immediately i'll have
ideas about what i think it's going to
be like and then i have to deal with
life as it happens which means it's
going to be
different the thing you want to order
will not be on the menu the
restaurant will not look like you want
to want to you have to serve yourself
well yeah
there's no way to whatever things are
different so the
gap put it in the simplest of terms
is expectation versus
result what does the character
expect and then what is the result
and how is that different and the truth
is we all
live with the gap every single day
every single day as part of our daily
experience this this is what's going to
happen all of us in this room now
because we're in the middle of the
afternoon have an expectation of what
is going to happen the rest of the day i
can tell you right now it won't work out
the way you think it's going to
something different will happen and
that's life so i realized in
constructing these stories
these autobiographical stories i needed
to
expose to the audience through the
storyteller
what the character wants and needs and
why it's so important
and what they are expecting very
specifically
with that naive narrator talking to the
audience saying
i'm going to go ask her for the date
it's going to be great it's going to be
great because she's not going to expect
that i'm going to ask her at all
and she's going to be so thrilled
because she i know she likes me
now i'm just giving you a lot of
information as what this character is
imagining and dreaming will happen and
then as that story goes along and it
gets to the point of
asking her and he gets to the point of
saying
i do you want to go to the are you going
to go to the prom she says oh yes i am
oh great um
you want to go with me now we're at that
point where he thinks
she's going to be thrilled
and what does she say why would i do
that
now big gap right there why would now
if we don't know how much he's invested
in this that response will mean
less we have to be
we have to be carrying his investment
into the scene with him
and so that we are hit by those
obstacles
as he navigates through that scene
it reminds me i had a college professor
that wrote on the chalkboard
expectations equals
disappointments now that sounds a little
negative
but i think in some ways if you yeah if
you approach it like that
then maybe you wouldn't get your hopes
dashed yeah
i thought that was really interesting i
know i i worked somewhere and i put that
up and so i said oh that's so negative
and i thought well actually it's more of
a realist
yeah or think of it this way flip it
around
imagine karen that you have expectations
for something
what's what's going on something you
want something you're going to do a
pursuit
and maybe it's the simplest thing of um
i'll make it very simple your ex you're
going to cook a meal
for you and david you're going to cook
this okay that's a meal you've never
cooked before
you have the recipe you have all the
ingredients your expectations is going
to be fantastic it's going to be gourmet
yeah
it's going to be gourmet right okay and
you make the whole thing and it's all
and it looks good and it smells good and
you serve it and it is gourmet and it's
exactly what you wanted
is that interesting now
the thing is if the if we always get the
expectations or if our characters always
get what they expect
it's not an interesting story because it
has no relationship
to life that's true it's too perfect
it's too planned
it probably wouldn't happen
but the thing is if you're fixing this
gourmet meal and it looks good and
smells good you know and david's coming
home and he comes home with kentucky
fried chicken
hey i got dinner now there's a gap
there is right now there's a gap and he
goes oh now
disappointment right see in other words
i think that disappointment thing is
very accurate
and that's what we live with every day
it's not a negative it's a reality
things do not turn out and it doesn't
mean things are worse
it just means they're different it could
be better a gap as things turn out even
better very true if you were making that
gourmet meal and you're going this
why am i doing this and this now your
expectation is going to be a disaster
because you've never made it before and
you don't have quite the right
ingredients
and you're using olives instead of
grapes or something and
and it turns out wonderful well there's
a gap
that's true a good good uh different
yeah expectations yeah
those disappointments so that's the gap
it's very important
in not just autobiographical but i think
in any
to me as i look at screenplays and stuff
like that every scene
there's a gap right sometimes line to
line there's a gap
someone asks a question do you want to
go out tonight
the answer is where did you put the
cheese
there's a gap do you want to go out
tonight i'm expecting an answer
i didn't get an answer i got a question
about where's the cheese
in fact i never get to ask that question
so those are little gaps
life goes like that we keep sort of
navigating and working our way finding
our way through a world that won't
give us exactly what we want because
that's just the way it works